Sollte jetzt wieder gehen.
Hoffentlich haben wir noch Quality Options.
Ja, wir haben auch noch Quality Options.
Alles gut.
Sehr nice.
Funktioniert wieder.
Sag mal, kennt sich jemand von euch aus mit Audio-Einstellungen,
wie man Kompressor und Noise Gates ordentlich einrichtet?
Ich habe jetzt zwar ein paar Tutorials gelesen und blicke so ungefähr durch,
was da wie welches Setting macht, aber so wirklich ist das nicht meine Welt.
Checkt das jemand?
Also soweit ich weiß, ist das...
Gut, Noise Gate ist, glaube ich, relativ einfach.
Alles, was irgendwie unter einem gewissen Level ist,
macht er das Mikrofon aus und er macht es wieder ein.
Ein, wenn es über einem gewissen Level ist.
Das ist sowas wie Push-to-Talk im Endeffekt in Discord.
Und das hier ist irgendwie die Zeit, wie lang mal über diesem Schwellwert sein muss.
Das habe ich gecheckt.
Also das kriege ich noch gebacken.
Na, guck.
Jetzt macht er...
Ich glaube, das ist schon an.
Wenn ich das jetzt ausschalte, guck, dann geht das Mikro nie ganz aus.
Wenn ich es einschalte, dann geht es unter einem gewissen Schwellwert aus.
Zack.
Aber...
Wie das genau funktioniert, ist mir nicht klar.
Also das ist okay, aber wie...
Was stelle ich beim Kompressor jetzt ein?
Mein Kompressor ist ja dafür da, dass es quasi...
Dass es nicht...
Dass wenn es übersteuert, dass euch nicht die Ohren wegfliegen
und dass wenn ich zu sehr flüstere, dass es nicht zu leise ist, ne?
Wenn ich das richtig...
Aber ich mache das jetzt mal wieder aus, weil...
Ich blicke da nicht durch.
Ich muss mir das erstmal nur angucken.
So, also.
Also, was machen wir heute?
Ich habe es ja schon vor einer Weile erzählt.
Ich habe mir ein bisschen neue Hardware gekauft.
Warum ist jetzt mein OBS ausgegangen?
Ich muss mal kurz meinen Browser reloaden.
Ich glaube, da ist es abgekackt.
Ja, wunderbar.
Nämlich das Streben geht noch.
Hätte mich auch gewundert, wenn nicht.
Lul.
Gut.
Also, was wir heute machen.
Ich habe es ja schon vor einer Weile erzählt.
Ich habe mir neue Hardware geholt.
Ihr kennt ja noch das...
Das alte Video wahrscheinlich.
Das da.
Das kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich noch.
Ne, Moment.
Das ist das ganz alte.
Das da.
Das kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich noch.
Also, aktuell ist es ja so, dass ich hier oben die fette 4HE-Kiste drinne habe.
Und mein Problem ist...
Also, an sich funktioniert das wunderbar, ne?
Die Kiste haut performance-mäßig alles weg.
Was ist, was man sonst so im Heimgebrauch an Servern da irgendwie am Start hat.
Also, da muss man sich keine Gedanken drum machen.
Das Problem ist bloß, dass...
Dass diese Kiste so ziemlich alles bei mir macht.
Also, die da, ne?
Die man hier jetzt quasi aufgeschraubt sieht.
Die macht bei mir alles.
Die macht...
ZFS-Rate mit 3x10TB-Platten.
Die macht Internet-Router.
Die macht Fernsehgedöns.
Inklusive Aufnahme, Live-TV.
Sonst war es Kodi-Gedöns.
Transcoding-Gedöns.
Home-Assistant-Gedöns.
Äh...
Ähm...
Nextcloud-Gedöns.
File-Server-Gedöns.
Die macht alles.
Ich muss es jetzt nicht weiter ausführen, glaube ich.
Und das Problem dabei ist so ein bisschen, dass, wenn ich die Kiste neu starten muss,
dass hier bei mir überhaupt nichts mehr funktioniert.
Die macht einfach alles.
Ähm...
So schön das ist, dass man hier ein bisschen was mit Power hat.
Erstens...
Ähm...
Habe ich die Power nie in der...
...Art und, weil man beachtet übrigens hier mal die tolle PC-Express-Karte falsch rum.
Ähm...
Ich habe die Power nie gebraucht.
Und Experimente, die ich da machen wollte mit Grafikkarten-Path-Through und Gedöns und so,
habe ich ein bisschen gebastelt.
Hat eigentlich auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Brauche ich aber nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache das anders.
Die Kiste behalte ich natürlich.
Aber...
Ähm...
Ich hebe mir die Kiste auf für Testzwecke.
Das heißt, wenn ich damit was basteln will,
oder so, habe ich immer eine Kiste, die kann ich hochfahren.
Aber ansonsten bleibt die aus.
Und das wird jetzt ersetzt durch einen Mikrotik-Router.
Also sprich, das Internet-Gedöns, was hier drüber läuft.
Ich habe ja einen Unity-Media-Anschluss und einen Telekom-Anschluss.
Telekom-Anschluss werde ich kündigen dieses Jahr.
Und Unity-Media umstellen auf 400 runter und 40 ab.
Das haben die ja schon auf Twitter damals geschrieben, dass das kein Problem ist.
Und...
Ähm...
Da kommt Telekom weg.
Aber aktuell sind es zwei Internet-Anschlüsse.
Äh...
Verschiedene VLANs.
Und WLANs.
Gibt's auch...
Hab ich auch, ähm...
Zwei Stück.
Offen.
Access-Point steht unten im Wohnzimmer.
Äh...
Das, was hier nebendran hängt, ist...
Der hängt immer noch da, aber der macht nichts mehr.
Der steht auch...
Hängt...
Stimmt gar nicht.
Hängt gar nicht mehr da.
Der billig-tp-ling-Access-Point, der liegt hier in der Kiste.
Ähm...
Das war's, wie gesagt.
Das Ding macht alles noch anders.
Die Internet-Geschichte, äh...
Netzwerk-Geschichte, die das macht, äh...
Wird ersetzt durch einen Mikrotik-Router mit fünf Ports.
Das reicht.
Da sind ja noch Switche dran.
Steck mal Böller rein.
Warum soll ich so Böller reinstecken?
Ähm...
Außerdem ist das doch nicht der 31.
Würdest du irgendwas, was 1200 Euro gekostet hat, Böller reinstecken?
Ich glaub so...
Ich glaub mit Wechsellaufwerken...
Ne, viel mehr.
Mit Platten.
Mit Platten viel mehr.
Allein schon so ne 10T-Platte hat ja schon 400 Euro oder so gekostet.
Ne, ne.
Allein schon die Festplatten haben 1200 Euro gekostet.
Das Ding hat...
Das Ding hat locker 1500...
2,5K gekostet insgesamt.
Ganz bestimmt steck ich da Böller rein.
Und auch noch 500 Euro Switch unten drunter.
10G, hier, da.
10G-Switch, übelst nice.
Brauch ich aber auch nicht.
Naja, wie dem auch sei...
Hier, Switch.
Wie dem auch sei, ähm...
Ich werd das jetzt ersetzen durch nen...
Fünf-Porn-Mikrotik-Router.
Der macht dann Internet, äh...
Die VLANs fürs...
Für Heimautomatisierung und Gedöns.
Hat alles Netzwerkmäßige.
Wird also einmal Mikrotik-Router.
Ja.
Dann, ähm...
Ne Kiste, die wir heute installieren werden.
Was heißt ne Kiste?
Aktuell ist es eigentlich nur nen Board mit nem RAM-Riegel drauf.
Und liegt hier neben mir.
So viel ist das ja nicht.
Das ist ne...
Ne Zwo-Kern- oder Vier-Kern-Zelleron-Billig-Kiste.
Aber für ein bisschen Home Assistant.
Und wie gesagt, ich brauch ja keine Leistung.
Das Ding eidelt sich den Hintern wund.
Das macht nichts, ja.
Ähm...
Und das kommt dann quasi...
Das ist quasi die Heimautomatisierungskiste.
Die hängt dann auch quasi im gleichen WLAN wie alle WLAN-Heimautomat...
Das klingt jetzt bescheuert.
Das ist das gleiche WLAN wie das WLAN.
Aber ist halt so.
Kommt das rein.
Also sprich, da kommt Heimautomatisierungszeug drauf.
Vielleicht das Fernsehzeug.
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Ich guck ja nicht viel Fernsehen.
Da kommt der NGX-Reverse-Box hier drauf.
Da kommt, äh...
Ja, muss ich mal gucken.
Also alles, was quasi nicht ins interne Netzwerk...
gesurft wird, kommt dann da drauf.
Und, ähm...
Dann hab ich noch ne...
ne Mini, so ein Singleboard-Computer mit SATA.
Wo einfach dann eine 10TB-Festplatte dran kommt.
Und die zweite kommt per USB dran und wird einfach nachts gestartet.
Wird drauf geair-synced.
Scheiß drauf.
Einfaches Setup schlägt im Prinzip...
Kompliziertes Setup.
Zwar nicht von der Performance her, aber...
Das kann da einfach weniger kaputt gehen.
ZFS, äh...
ZFS...
RAID, ähm...
ZFS RAID...
Was ist das?
Z...
RAID 1 ist das, glaub ich.
RAID 5, quasi.
ZFS...
Ist geil.
ZFS ist geil.
Äh...
Frisst halt RAM ohne Ende.
Die Sache ist, ähm...
Die...
Ich benutze davon im Endeffekt ja auch fast nichts an geilen Features.
Ja, ich repliziere nix.
Ich...
Mach kaum Snapshots.
Es ist einfach nur da, um da zu sein.
Deswegen wird das jetzt relativ rudimentär und billig wieder...
Eine Platte auf die interne...
Auf das interne NAS.
Äh...
Ist 4 drauf.
Zweite 10T-Platte an USB dran.
Einmal in der Nacht wird gesynct.
Airclown, sonstwas.
Vielleicht noch Cloud-technisch.
Und dann ist Ruhe.
Aus ist.
Alles in 4Ms oder sogar Docker.
Also, aktuell habe ich so ziemlich alles an Virtualisierungsgedöns am Start, was es...
Was es irgendwie gibt.
Außer Hyper-V.
Ich hab hier auf dem Desktop, habe ich hier vor allem meine Workstation, auf, ähm...
Auf dem Server habe ich ein paar KVM...
KVM-Kisten drauf.
Kann ich euch mal zeigen.
Hier...
kann ich euch mal zeigen.
Äh...
Ja...
Ähm...
Deshalb laufen aktuell KVM VRMs drauf.
Ich hoffe, man sieht...
Ja, dass sieht man zwar nicht.
Ich seh's in der Vorschau.
Das sind meine KVM VRMs.
Dann hab ich...
ähm...
Auf dem Server selbst.
2 Punkt 100...
Das ist...
äh...
Wahnsinnig aktuell.
Hopp ich hab es schon ewig...
Haha...
...ewig neverma aktualisiert.
Öhm...
Läuft.
ist jetzt meine, meine fette, meine fette
ähm, 4HE-Kiste,
ne? Äh, ja doch, meine fette
4HE-Kiste. Auf dem Server selbst
laufen dann jede Menge, jede Menge
LXC-Container.
Das sind, ähm,
die haben tolle Namen, ne? Wo wir gerade dabei
sind. Ich hab die Twitch-Emotes genommen,
die, die finde ich am besten
zum, zur Funktion vom jeweiligen
Server passen. Also sprich, Dancegame
ist gegen Werbung. Äh,
Elegiggle ist, warum auch immer, ich weiß
nicht, was ich mir dabei gedacht hab, dass die Emote verwendet
keine Sau mehr eigentlich heute.
Ist der File-Server und Backup.
Ähm, Failfish, weil
es immer rumbuckt, ist der
Netzwerk-Install-Server. Giftblitz,
weil man halt Zeugs draufschiebt, ist
Nextcloud. G-Baited
ist, ja,
war mir, war ich mir zu fein.
War ich mir, die muss wahrscheinlich
G-Baited heißen, weil sie keine Beschreibung
hat. Ich weiß es nicht mehr, was G-Baited war.
Ähm,
ja,
anscheinend auch wichtig, weil sie läuft,
ja.
G-Baited.
Äh, Wohio
ist, ähm, äh,
äh, I-Map-Mail-
Backup-Zeugs von Google-GMX
und Gedöns.
Das Ding hat einen sprechenden Namen. Das schiebt
Kontaktdaten zur Fritzbox,
weil die Fritzbox und das Fritzphone
natürlich keinen offenen Standard wie Caldaf oder so
kann. Das musste immerhin das eigene Fritzbox-Format
umwandeln. Und Comanbra
ist, äh, TV-Server.
Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung mehr, was
G-Baited ist. Ich glaub, der DNS.
Nee, nee, der DNS ist schon hier oben.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was G-Baited ist.
Kann schon mal.
Wofür brauchst du einen PXE-Server zu Hause?
Ja, haben, ne?
Hat keinen tieferen Sinn. Wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich einfach, der ist ja auch aus, wie das
hieß, wahrscheinlich einfach, ach nee,
ah, ich weiß noch wozu, zum Windows installieren.
Das war, das war zum Windows installieren,
weil ich, äh, nie Windows, ähm,
USB-Sticks am Start
hab, hab ich mal eingerichtet,
dass man Windows über,
ähm, äh, wie hieß das?
Windows PE oder so, Boot
installieren kann. Das heißt, wenn ich hier mal Windows installieren
muss, weil einer meiner Dinger mit
Windows drauf kaputt ist, kann ich das da,
ja, oder ich könnte auch, ich könnte auch simpel Netboot
drüber, drüber machen und so.
Aber wahrscheinlich fung, wahrscheinlich funktioniert
es gar nicht, weil das hatte ich schon ewig, guck mal hier.
Last used at, das ist
uralt, das ist
einfach,
ne, einfach da, das verwende
ich im Prinzip eigentlich so gut wie klar.
Moment, last used ergibt keinen Sinn.
State running?
Last used at.
Kann das sein, dass der einfach schon so lange
runnt? Ich geh mal davon aus, was haben wir denn für einen Moment?
Wollen wir mal gucken. So allzu lange
Uptime können wir eigentlich gar
nicht haben. Naja,
okay, läuft schon
ein bisschen. Ich bilde mir ein, ich
hab ihn erst neu gestartet, aber anscheinend doch nicht.
Läuft schon ein bisschen, ja.
Schafft der
normale Windows-Desktop-Rechner nicht unbedingt.
Aber weil der den einfach neu
booten muss wegen Updates, ne. Hätte ich Updates
gemacht hier mal, irgendwann, dann,
dann hätte ich auch nicht so viel Uptime.
261 Tage, schon ordentlich.
Genau, und
ja, und dann habe ich auch noch
ein paar Docker-VMs, wo wir noch dabei sind,
oder Docker-Container. Wir haben ja hier
die Heimatomatisierungs-VM.
Ich sag ja aktuell,
das Ding, ein großer Single-Point-of-Failure-Server.
Das ist meine Heimatomatisierungs-VM.
Und wenn man
da drauf guckt, das ist
die da,
die, da mache ich regelmäßig,
regelmäßig Updates. So.
Da läuft auch noch ein Docker drauf.
Also ich habe viel zu viel
Wildwuchs im Endeffekt.
Ja, da läuft alles mögliche drauf.
Das ist, das ist viel, das ist total wir.
Das ist, ja, das ist im Endeffekt,
ist das zu viel des Guten, ja.
Ihr müsstet erstmal die Netzwerksettings sehen dazu,
die kann ich euch jetzt aber nicht zeigen.
Ich habe in meiner, in meiner PFSense-Filewall-VM,
habe ich irgendwie
sechs oder sieben Interfaces.
Also fast auch für jedes WLAN,
auch ein extra Interface.
Ähm.
Es ist auch übertrieben kompliziert.
Das heißt, wie gesagt, das Ding ist
ein rieser Single, single-Point-of-Failure.
Und ähm ja.
Warum nicht alles unter Docker?
Weil ich der Meinung bin, wenn man Docker ordentlich macht,
dann ähm, macht man sich eigene Container.
Weil eines der schönen Sachen von self-hosted ist ja,
dass man weiß, was man laufen hat, was du bei, wir installieren Blind von Docker, hab jetzt nur auch wieder nicht hast, ja, und wenn du ein bisschen standardabweichende Sachen machen willst, dann fährst du einfach mit einem System, was du ändern kannst im Betrieb besser als mit Docker, das ist einfach die Frage, was man braucht, ja, zum Beispiel diese Home Assistant Geschichte ist als Docker wunderbar, da ist es mir nämlich wurscht, was drunter ist, da sage ich einfach hier, Home Assistant Start, paar Addons, gut ist,
für meine ganzen LXC-Kisten, da will ich ja selbst was drauf machen, ja, ich will ja, sprich, ich will auch mal per Kommandozeile auf die TV-Server drauf und da ein bisschen rumbasteln und sowas, LXC ist halt einfach mehr ein komplettes System, wohingegen Docker halt eine Einzelanwendung ist,
das ist halt immer die Frage, was man braucht, das ist beides, hat beides seine Daseinsberechtigung und deswegen hab ich halt auch alles und alles ist mir einfach zu kompliziert, das ist zwar,
architektonisch, also von der Architektur her ist das, ist das alles ganz nice, ja, und das ist im Prinzip auch das richtige Tool für den richtigen Zweck, aber es ist einfach unnötig daheim, ja, das ist komplett Overkill,
deswegen, ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob ich auf die Kisten, die wir heute installieren, überhaupt die Home Assistant Docker-Installation drauf mache oder nicht einfach direkt Python Virtual Env und drauf gehauen.
Was benutzt du für eine Distro, VM und Shell?
Also das hier ist, und das benutze ich auf der Arbeit auch, also das ist im Prinzip das, was ich benutze, ist I3 als Window Manager, ähm, was wolltest du wissen, äh, Distro, VM und Shell, also wie gesagt, äh, also, okay, Distro ist Manjaro, das ist ein, eine Arch Linux, äh, Variante, äh, Window Manager ist I3 auf Xorg, äh, who cares, Wayland, ähm, und Shell, das ist ZSH,
äh, mit, mit TMAX im Gnome Terminal, ja, so sieht's aus, genau, und, ähm, ja, ich hab jetzt ja die Hardware hier schon eine Weile rumliegen, ich muss selbst mal nachgucken, was das jetzt eigentlich für ein Board genau ist, was ich mir da geholt hab,
ich hab nämlich wirklich irgendwas, ich hab irgendwas sehr Energiesparendes gesucht, und ich muss mal kurz drauf gucken, ob man irgendwo erkennt, was das für ein Board ist, ah, hier, S-Rock,
Ding, dumm, dumm, dumm,
S-Rock,
J,
das ist nix dolles,
ja, das da,
aber für Heimatomatisierungszeug ist es
deutlich, deutlich angenehmer als ein Raspberry Pi,
Raspberry Pi braucht alles, äh,
ist einfach langsam, wenn du da, wenn du da Home Assistant
mit einer gewissen Menge drauf machst,
wenn du das Ding mal neu starten musst, wart's dir ja
gefühlt fünf Minuten, ne,
was hat das Grill zum Geschenk gesagt, noch nix,
das hat's nämlich noch gar nicht,
genau, und dieses Ding, da hab ich mir
gekauft,
für
Ablösung für mein Heimatomatisierungszeug,
ah, ja, okay, es hatte schon, es, okay, es ist nicht nur ein Dual-Core, es ist sogar ein Quad-Core-Celeron,
irgendwas, und ich hab das einfach genommen, weil es das billigste Board war, und das stromsparendste Board, was, äh, PCI Express hat sogar, zwei, oder, nee, eins, eins, das andere ist eine Spiegelung unten drunter, äh, hat das eins oder zwei?
Eins.
Was ein PCI Express hatte, und, ähm, das war wichtig, weil ich ne, ne TV-Karte drauf hab, drauf haben möchte, äh, mit, äh, Quad-Tuner, und das Ding ist halt PCI Express.
Fertig. Billigste Board ever, kostet, kostet auch nix im Endeffekt, das kostet, das, ja, das kriegst du irgendwie, wahrscheinlich, wenn du ein bisschen suchst, kriegst du's für 70 Euro oder so.
Also, absolut kein Vergleich zu, ähm, zu hier, 2,5 Euro.
5K-Kiste, ist natürlich auch ein Witz von der Leistung her dagegen.
So.
Und das installieren wir heute, und richten ein paar Sachen drauf ein, und, äh, vor allem, ähm, ich, ich wollte heute halt mal auch streamen, weil heute habt ihr, sind halt viele Leute auch daheim, und das wär jetzt irgendwie auch ein bisschen blöd, wenn ich heute nicht, nicht mal den Stream anwerfen würde, und, ähm, ich muss auch ein bisschen was machen, wo wir einfach ein bisschen labern können, und, ähm, wo ich mich nicht so sehr wie bei Proggers konzentrieren muss.
Also.
Ja, und das Ding ist halt, jetzt kann ich meine Makros mal verwenden, das Ding ist halt wirklich, das ist stromsparend, und es ist, im Prinzip ist es Crap, ja, aber, ähm, für, für so ein bisschen 24-7, ich mein, das läuft halt 24-7, und ein bisschen Heimatomatisierungszeug, Fernsehaufnehmen, Kram, und ein bisschen Kleinkram, ist das vollkommen ausreichend, ja, da wird einmal nachts ein Backup-Phone gezogen, und wenn's verreckt, verreckt's halt.
So, what?
Dann, dann geht's halt mal einen halben Tag nicht, oder einen Tag, bis ich bei Amazon was Neues bestellt hab.
Ja, das ist, im Prinzip ist die 4 HE-Kiste Overkill, und zu viel auf einer Sache drauf.
Das ist echt ein Problem.
So, ähm, ich hoffe jetzt mal, das funktioniert, weil, ich hab das jetzt so gemacht, ich hab hier nen, so, die letzte OBS-Version, anscheinend, äh, ich hab hier mal meine Elgato angeschlossen,
und wir schalten jetzt mal das Dinge ein, und gucken, ja, wir schalten das, ne, vorher müssen wir nochmal Ubuntu downloaden.
Ich bin ein, ich bin, bei mir ist das, hab ich ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt, ich find das eigentlich lustig, ne, die meisten Leute sagen ja, Ubuntu, so, auf dem Desktop, und auf dem Server, dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, äh, Debian, äh, CentOS, oder halt ein echtes Red Hat, oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ja, manche stehen auch auf Suse,
und, äh, in neuster Zeit.
Ganz, ganz, äh, im Trend für irgendwelche Minimalsysteme, so Alpin, und sowas in der Richtung.
Bei mir ist es genau umgedreht.
Ich find lustigerweise, auf dem Desktop kann ich Ubuntu nicht ausstehen, krieg Anfälle, wenn ich Ubuntu verwenden muss, auf dem Desktop.
Auf dem Desktop kommt bei mir bloß Manjaro mit i3, ähm, aber, auf meinem Serversystem, die ich privat betreibe, ist alles Ubuntu-Server, weil es mir persönlich einfach am besten gefällt.
Ich find das, Ubuntu hat, Ubuntu-Server hat genau die richtige Auswahl.
An Aktualität von Paketen, das, was Debian oftmals irgendwie nicht hat, äh, Aktualität von Paketen, äh, ordentlicher, ordentlicher Support, sinnvolle vorinstallierte Sachen, ähm, ein paar Ausrutscher, wie ihre komische YAML-basierte Netzwerkkonfig haben sie, aber ansonsten, find ich, ist Ubuntu einfach so servermäßig das beste Gesamtpaket.
Aber das ist ein bisschen Geschmackssache, und letztendlich nimmt sich auch alles nicht so viel.
Wir müssen jetzt nämlich erst nochmal, ähm, ja, was geht mit meinem Rechner, warum ist denn da so am, was ist denn da so ausgelassen?
Das ist, OBS, na gut, OBS darf ausgelastet sein.
So, ähm, so, ich schalt mal wieder um.
Äh, wir müssen uns erstmal das neueste Ubuntu-Server-Dings downloaden und auf den USB-Stick ziehen.
Jetzt ist bloß die Preisfrage, was nehm ich denn? Nehm ich ein 18.10? Da muss ich nämlich nächstes Jahr updaten, oder nehm ich ein 18.04 LTS?
Ich glaub, ich nehm ein 18.04 LTS. Einfach aus dem Grund, das haben sie, glaub ich, fünf Jahre supportet, dass es so drauf und Ruhe haben.
Hier muss ich quasi spätestens nach nem Jahr updaten, sonst gibt's keine Repos mehr zum ordentlich updaten.
Und, ähm, das mach ich eh nicht. Insofern nicht in dem 18.04.
So, und ich glaub, wir brauchen den Alternative-Installer, muss ich mal gucken, weil die haben...
Die haben mit irgendwie einer der letzten Versionen ihren Installer geändert und der war übelster Crap.
Du konntest kaum was machen. Wir gucken mal.
Live-Server, ja, das ist Fail, das ist die falsche.
Äh, Alternative-Dingsbums, brau ma.
Das ist Fail. Diesen komischen Live-Installer von Ubuntu kann man komplett knicken, da kannst du gar nix machen.
Kannst du nicht mal Festplattenverschlüsselung, ähm...
Warum AdWoblos, was war Knärbär, was meinste?
Was meinste?
Äh, Standard, blablabla, AMD-Arm, ja, den da wollen wir haben.
Das Install-Ding, ja, du kannst in dem neuen Ubuntu-Installer, kannst du irgendwie, kannst beispielsweise keine Partitionierung mal richtig machen, du kannst irgendwie, ähm, keine, was war's?
Ich glaub, du kannst keine Plattenverschlüsselung mehr richtig einrichten während der Installation, das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Guck mal, das Ding hier.
New Installer.
Warte mal, vielleicht gibt's ein paar Bilder davon.
Ja, das da, das da.
Du kannst im Prinzip nicht viel machen, außer den Namen angeben.
Und, ähm, du konntest, du konntest hier auch keine, keine Verschlüsselung mehr einschalten.
Es, es gingen ein paar Sachen nicht, die mir mega auf den Sack gegangen sind, deswegen nehm ich den Alternative-Installer.
Und das hier ist der normale.
Der, genau.
Das, der ist das, Mist.
So.
Ähm, mach mal einen USB-Stick rein.
Ich hab hier mit weißer Voraussicht schon mal einen hingeschmissen.
Ist die Musik-Lautstärke eigentlich so okay?
What?
The following device can be...
Ja, ja, ist okay, mach.
Hat er hoffentlich schon connected.
Einer Musik, wo sie im Hintergrund labern, ist nervig.
Dev SD.
Na, wahrscheinlich B, hä?
Die Musik geht mir auf den Keks.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Äh, 24-7 Chill-Music.
24, 24-7.
Rainy Jazz.
Oh, nee.
Äh, ne.
Äh, Overwatch-Musik.
Ah, warte mal.
Overwatch Christmas Extended.
Ja.
De, de, de, de, de, de, de, de...
Dann wirst du aber verrückt mit der Zeit, weil das loopt nach ner Minute.
das loopt nach einer minute das hält man nicht lange aus
das haben wir sonst noch wo wo wo ich sonst noch dass wir schon zu gechillt
grills im cover er klickt damit auch gesungen
wir machen dings ja wie hieß die dna den war an dass auch immer entspannt ihr
panische finger skills das übelst entspannt monka toss darf man jetzt ja
gar nicht verspielt oder viel zu leise dass das ist schön entspannt
also bloß gucken dass nicht zu laut ist so gehen wir rüber hat er kam jetzt
downloadet der download noch was ist das ist das hier auch der usb stick ja 16 g
5 15 g sind seiner usb stick aus
so die einfache variante also die die zurzeit angesagteste variante generell
einen iso auf den usb stick zu bekommen ist tatsächlich ich weiß nicht genau ich
habe das eigentlich für sd karten ich weiß nicht so genau warum man eine
elektronen anwendung braucht mit zig mb speicherverbrauch und 150 mb
download größe oder so und was weiß ich wieviel dass ich wieviel ram verbrauch
also gehen an ist das nicht so 160 mb ram verbrauch für isos auf einen image
machen ich habe keine ahnung ehrlich gesagt man kann einfach auch das wird
das aber wissen sie laut immer schwierig einzuschätzen bei der klassik die die
dass immer das schwankt immer so
anstatt einfach die CD auf den USB-Stick zu DDen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sich Etcher oder sowas durchgesetzt hat.
Keine Ahnung, ja.
Man könnte einfach sagen, DD...
Ich meine, DD ist halt so der Disk-Destroyer schlechthin.
Es heißt übrigens, DD hat einen ganz abgetretenen Namen.
Also das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht.
Genau, es heißt Copy & Convert oder Convert & Copy heißt DD.
Und wer kennt die Story dahinter, warum Copy & Convert oder Convert & Copy DD heißt?
Das ist irgendwie bescheuern.
Das müsste eigentlich Copy & Convert, das müsste eigentlich CNC oder so heißen.
Oder CC oder CCNC oder so.
Aber warum heißt das DD?
Also ich würde...
Um das aufzuklären, warum das DD heißt, das ist...
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Story stimmt.
Die Story ist...
Die Sache ist, dass CC schon der C-Compiler ist.
Und die mussten das Ding einfach DD nennen, weil CC schon belegt war.
So weit die Story.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Aber das kann ich mir zu der damaligen Zeit gut vorstellen.
Jetzt ist es wieder übelst leise.
Das ist Fail.
Ich lasse jetzt einfach auf 30 und wenn es zu laut ist, müsste ich was sagen.
So, also mit DD ist es jetzt nämlich einfach drauf.
Ups.
Da muss man halt ein bisschen aufpassen bei DD, ne?
Download.
So, wie hieß der?
Krempel Ubuntu.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal nach.
DD.
Home.
Test.
Best.
Downloads Ubuntu.
Bla bla bla.
OF ist Def SDB.
Haben wir vorhin nachgeguckt.
Können wir nochmal nachgucken.
Ich habe den USB-Stick angestöpselt.
Das ist der Meinung, er ist SDB.
Also nice, wunderbar.
SDB.
Und sagen wir mal Block Size 1M.
Ja.
Also ein bisschen zackiger geht.
So, und bei DD muss man jetzt doppelt und dreifach ganz genau gucken, dass das Kram auch stimmt.
Weil DD juckt es überhaupt nicht.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier bei OF aus Versehen SDA schreibe und SDA ist meine...
Achso, ja gut, das Ganze muss ich als Hut machen.
Darf ich nicht.
Dann wäre mein Dings im Arsch.
Deswegen könnte ich mir vorstellen...
Dass, ähm, ja, jetzt, äh, USB-Sticks so vor sich hin.
Ähm, achso, ja, man kriegt, wenn man wissen möchte, was DD macht,
ähm, kann man sich den DD-Befehl raussuchen.
Irgendwo da.
Und man kann den Kill-Dings an DD schicken.
Und wenn man Glück hat, macht dann DD eine Status-Ausgabe.
Was es jetzt aber irgendwie nicht macht.
Normalerweise sollte es DD machen.
So, also das heißt, man kriegt bei DD nicht mit, was es gerade kopiert.
Das geht aber relativ einfach.
Man kann einfach, wir brechen das mal ab.
Ja.
Wir brechen es ab.
Also wenn wir das abgebrochen haben dann irgendwann, dann zeige ich euch, wie man DD anzeigen lassen kann, wie viel es eigentlich kopiert.
Was ist denn das Problem?
Ist der USB-Stick nicht richtig drin oder was?
DD, du darfst jetzt abbrechen.
Ah, jetzt.
Gut.
Jetzt ist er abgebrochen.
Genau.
Und, ähm, man kann einfach sagen, habe ich Dings, habe ich einfach installiert?
Ja.
Man kann einfach sagen, ähm, man nimmt einen DD, pipet das durch PV und dann wird er in DD.
Und gut, es, was das macht, ist, PV ist, äh, quasi das liest Eingabe und schreibt es nach Ausgabe und sagt ja, wie viel es durch, äh, es durchläuft.
Das heißt, im Prinzip kriegt man so, muss man eigentlich jetzt beides Blocks heißen?
Das heißt, angeben weiß ich gar nicht.
Im Prinzip kriegt man so raus, was DD treibt.
Ja, und genau das, was, was Knärbel schreibt, man kann damit auch einfach die Festplatten kopieren.
Das ist überhaupt kein, überhaupt kein Ding.
So, hier brauchen wir keinen DD.
Anscheinend brauchen wir hier das, das Sudo vor, oder?
Reicht das, wenn man das komplett macht?
Mal gucken.
Ne, da muss das Sudo davon.
Das ist logisch.
Beim Lesen nicht, aber beim Schreiben.
So, und jetzt zeigt es nämlich PV an, was es treibt.
Und, oder auch nicht.
Warum nicht?
Muss ich denn irgendwas verkehrt gemacht?
Eigentlich, also eigentlich sollte das genauso funktionieren.
Wir können mit DS dann nachgucken, was das, ähm, was das kopiert.
Ja, das kopiert.
Das kopiert auf dem USB-Stick.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht, warum die D nichts anzeigt, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist blöd, oder?
Das ist doch eigentlich genau richtig.
Naja, warten wir es mal ab, bis es auf dem USB-Stick geschrieben hat.
Also, Kaskorian, das kann man machen.
Das, äh, versorgt, äh,
es verursacht halt ein bisschen Last auf dem Rechner.
Keine Lemon Bar.
Nein, es ist, ähm, äh, wie heißt das Ding?
I3, äh, I3-Status-RS.
Das ist irgendeine, irgendeine Rust-Geschichte.
Rust.
Raster.
Ja, I3-Status-Rust ist es.
Ist keine Lemon Bar.
Es gibt ja, ah, okay, er ist fertig.
Er ist fertig, na dann.
Ähm, warum PV nichts angezeigt hat.
Also, im Prinzip ist das,
das ist die richtige Variante, wenn man sich was anzeigen lassen will.
So, und nun können wir unseren,
unser Board mit dem USB-Stick,
man sinkt hinterher, man weiß ja nie,
ähm, mit dem USB-Stick booten
und hoffen, dass es funktioniert.
Ich versuche das mal dran zu stapseln, gerade.
Im Moment, wir gehen mal rüber
und ich schalte mal auf die Elgato um.
Und wir gucken mal, ob der jetzt vom USB-Stick bootet.
Ups.
Ah, ich muss noch kurz Kopfhörer ansetzen,
sonst schon mal absetzen und schmeißen.
Und mal gucken, ob es startet.
Ach so, vielleicht sollte ich noch eine Tastatur anschließen,
das wäre nicht schlecht.
Aber man sieht schon mal, was er macht.
Er ist schon mal der Meinung, er ist auf Billig-S-Rock Mainboard,
was erstmal ganz gut ist.
Ja, wunderbar.
Ähm, was nu?
Elgato, wo ist denn jetzt das Problem?
Hallo, Elgato.
Was genau hat das Ding für Probleme?
Okay, dann stoppse ich das Elgato-Teil nochmal ab und wieder an.
Auch okay.
Ich bring das ja mehr.
Hm?
Ha!
Ach nee, Moment, das hat jetzt ja das gebootet, was schon auf der Platte drauf ist.
Und halbe...
Bescheid.
Äh, muss ich mal eine Tastatur dran stöpseln und, ähm...
mal entknoten.
Und rebooten.
So.
Das ist ganz schönes Gefuddel hier.
Weil das Board liegt quasi...
Warum hat die Tastatur eigentlich zwei USB-Anschlüsse?
Hm.
Das muss ich gleich mal beim Hersteller nachgucken.
Warum?
Kennt ihr das, dass man USB-Anschlüsse immer falsch rum rein stöpselt?
Immer.
Aber beim vierten Anlauf oder so hat man festgestellt, es ist doch...
verkehrt rum oder richtig rum gewesen.
So.
Okay, meine...
Okay, starten wir mal neu.
Was muss man drücken? Entfernen?
Was muss man drücken fürs BIOS? Ich seh ja nix, weil die Elgato nicht mag.
Ah, okay.
Ha.
Oh. Entfernen, einfach entfernen.
Herrmann.
Herrmann, umgutes.
Äh, wo kann man einstellen, was man booten will?
Ja.
Ich will nicht Ubuntu, ich will das da booten.
Hä.
Wie sagt man dem denn von was er booten soll?
Da muss man...
Ne, da muss man wahrscheinlich beim booten irgendwie...
Achso, ne, hier kann man das wohl auch auswählen.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ha!
Bam!
Funktioniert doch.
Moment, ich muss mir das hier...
Ich muss mir das hier selbst erstmal Vollbild machen, weil sonst seh ich das nicht.
Ich seh...
Ich mach das selbst grade über die OBS-Vorschau, das ist voll Fail, ja.
Ich hab nicht, ich hab nicht den Monitor-Pass-Route oder so, ich mach das mit übelstem Lack über die, über die, äh, über die Elgato-Vorschau grade.
Okay, also, Language ist Englisch, ist okay.
Ja, ich drück ne Taste, das macht ne Minute später was, das ist übelst irritierend.
Äh, nein, wir sind in EU, nicht Zimbabwe.
So, dann sind wir in Germanie.
Wir sind auch nicht in Zimbabwe.
Ja, äh, Dings, US ist, ist in Ordnung.
Kann ich mit leben.
Yes, Tastatur-Layout detecten, please.
Ypsilon, jawoll.
Yes, wir haben auch nen Ö-Key.
Drücke den Ö-Key.
Das ist ja so als gefühlt, nein, wir sind keine Franzosen.
Wir haben detected, dass du DE-No-Dead-Keys hast, jawoll.
So, das geht jetzt relativ gut.
So, das geht jetzt relativ schnell und danach kann ich mich per SSH einloggen.
Guck mal, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab nen Add-On in meinem Meme-Board drinne.
Ich kann jetzt, zeig euch was, ich hab jetzt im Vollbild, ihr seht jetzt ja quasi Vollbild-Elgato
und ich kann trotzdem Bilder einblenden.
Ist nice, oder?
Ich hab jetzt nämlich nen Browser, Browser, äh, Browser-Output vom Meme-Tool.
Das ist, das ist, äh, schon pock.
Pock, ja.
So, Host-Name.
Den, wie heißt der jetzt?
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen nen guten Namen für das Ding.
Korgas.
Oder, ähm, was hab ich denn noch nicht?
Ich hab schon so viel, jetzt, Korgas, ja, Korgas ist gut.
Ich mach jetzt selber Korgas.
Oder Broggas.
Ich hab übrigens Broggas als Domain doch registriert, ne?
Die wir letztens im, im Stream gesehen haben.
Fullname for new user.
Max.
Hoch, wahnsinnig secures Passwort.
Nicht Poggas, Broggas.
Äh, ja, ja, das ist schon okay.
Timezone, jawoll.
So sieht's aus.
De-de-de-de-de-de-de.
Ja, ja, das ist okay.
Mach weiter.
Use entire disk and set up encrypted LVM.
Das klingt gut.
Hauptsache man muss den, den Crap nicht selber machen.
Cleverer Installer.
Was möchten Sie formatieren?
Die Festplatte?
Oder den USB-Stick, von dem Sie gerade...
Was, muted?
Bin ich muted?
Jebaited, äh, ah.
Weil das hätte, das hätte tatsächlich sein können, dass ich muted bin.
Weil, ähm, ich hab ja die, die...
Ich hab ja die Szene im OBS gewechselt.
Huge Jebait.
De-de-de-de-de-de-de.
Yes.
Moin, Onkel Bingo.
Passwort Encryption Phrase.
Ja.
Das werdet ihr jetzt nicht erfahren.
Oh, nee.
Also, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Sorry, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Ja, ja, mach einfach weiter.
Yes.
Das Bild ist über dem Dialog, ey.
Warum?
Ich hab das extra unten rechts in die Ecke gemacht, weil das immer komplett schwarz ist auf der Konsole.
So, aber danach können wir uns eh gleich per SSH einloggen und gut ist.
Genau, proggas123 Passwort.
Moin, Danny D.
Ich bin begeistert, wie schnell mittlerweile so eine Ubuntu-Installation ist.
Ich kann mich noch an die ersten paar Versionen erinnern.
Die haben teilweise echt irgendwie eine halbe Stunde oder so rumgerödelt.
Aber das lag wahrscheinlich auch daran, dass die Rechner damals langsamer waren.
Ob ich mich dran erinnere?
Ich hab damals, hab ich mich für super clever gehalten.
Und ich hab damals auf einem ollen Rechner, hab ich ein Ubuntu, was war denn das?
Keine Ahnung.
Acht, 8.10 oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder neun Punkt, also, alt.
Ja, ganz alt.
Hab ich, ähm, ein Ubuntu installiert auf einem USB-Stick RAID 1.
Da hab ich damals übelst gefeiert für, weil ich gedacht hab, boah, ist das geil.
Ist das der RAID 1, du brauchst keine Platten, oh.
Ja.
Ja, da hab ich mich übelst gefeiert damals, dass ich ein USB-Stick RAID 1 hab.
Ich glaub, das hätte man nur noch toppen können mit nem Micro-SD-Karten-RAID 5 oder sowas.
Das wär doch mal was, oder?
Was sagt ihr?
Was?
Das wär doch mal was.
Ein Micro-SD-Karten-RAID 5.
Sodass auch schön alle SD-Karten gleichmäßig kaputt gehen.
Auf, installieren, go, go.
Mach nicht so lange rum.
Yo, Dog.
Ein klein Proxy.
Proxy ist komplett overrated.
Äh, Quai, was hast du denn installiert?
Für ne Distribution?
Was ist denn aktuell für ne Distribution sinnvoll für so Low-End-Hardware?
Vor ner Weile hab ich bei meiner Mutter aufm Notebook, die hat auch so ein olles, olles,
ich weiß noch nicht, ob's noch ein Toolcore ist, so ein olles Ding, da hab ich, ähm,
Elementary drauf installiert.
Das läuft gut.
So, was wollen wir haben?
Wir haben hier, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm,
so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm,
so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so
ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein,
ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm,
so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein, ähm, so ein,
Vor einer Weile habe ich bei meiner Mutter auf dem Notebook, die hat auch so ein olles, olles, ich weiß noch nicht, ob es ein Toolcore ist, so ein olles Ding.
Da habe ich, ähm, Elementary drauf installiert.
Das läuft gut.
So, was wollen wir haben?
Wir wollen eigentlich nur einen OpenSSH-Server, dass wir uns da drauf eindocken können.
Das ist eigentlich alles.
Mehr wollen wir nicht.
So, und jetzt machen wir hinne.
Ich meine, das Installieren geht schon relativ schnell, ne?
Das ist eine SD-Karte, äh, eine SSD und ein USB-Stick, ein ordentlicher.
Also das geht schon zackig.
Ich kann mich noch an Zeiten erinnern, da musste ich mal, ah, das ist jetzt wirklich, das ist jetzt wirklich lang her.
Ähm, da habe ich mal auf einem Server im Rechenzentrum Red Hat, was war das, 4 oder so installiert auf einer Datenbank.
Das waren damals, glaube ich, 6 CDs.
Da hast du wirklich 3 Stunden davor gestartet und hast CDs gewechselt.
Das war ein echt, das war ein richtiger Gap, übelster Gap.
Das war krank, ey.
Weil, und vor allem hat es damals so lange gedauert, weil sich irgendjemand, ähm, überlegt hat, so in glorreicher Voraussicht,
dass sie auf ihren Datenbanken, das ist kein Witz, ne, dass sie auf ihren Datenbanken eine Vollinstallation, eine Red Hat Vollinstallation haben wollen.
Also sprich, alles, komplett.
Überall ein Häkchen machen.
Man durfte auch nicht im Installer einfach sagen, Vollinstallation, nein, man musste Custom-Installation machen und überall ein Häkchen hin.
Die wollten eine, die wollten nicht eine Vollinstallation.
Die wollten eine volle, vollständige Vollinstallation haben und da hast du dann alle 6 CDs für gebraucht.
Das hat ewig gedauert.
Ja, ich, ich denke mal, mittlerweile wollen sie sowas auch nicht mehr.
Das ist schon bescheuert, oder?
True Story.
Ist das halt, so in Zeiten, als ich noch Turnschuh-Administrator war.
Also, im Prinzip Azubi, der rumlaufen musste.
Ach, ist das Azubi, ja.
Ist schon ein bisschen her.
Ist auf jeden Fall über 10 Jahre her.
Noch länger.
Ja, schon ein bisschen.
12 Jahre oder so.
Ja.
Und ich war schon relativ spät.
Cool Story, Bro.
Ja, was, was soll ich denn sonst machen, außer bei der, wenn wir uns die Ubuntu-Installation angucken?
So super intense Gameplay ist das jetzt ja nicht.
Ich meine, das ist voll immersive, das Gameplay.
Da kann man nichts anderes sagen, ja.
Wir können ja mal deine IHK-Prüfung.
Im Stream angucken.
Das Problem ist, ich hätte schon, ich hätte schon mal aus, also, just for fun, hätte ich schon mal eine IHK-Prüfung aufgemacht im Stream.
Und wir hätten uns das mal zusammen angeguckt, weil die sind teilweise echt sowas von bescheuert.
Das Problem ist, die gehen da voll ab, ja.
Die, die, die machen da das Ultra-Geheimnis drum.
Um die IHK-Prüfung.
Ja.
Also, ich sag mal so.
Also, ähm.
Wenn ich die nicht im Stream runterladen muss.
Wenn einer von euch.
Wenn einer von euch mir einen Link schickt, wo zufällig eine IHK-Prüfung dahinter ist, dann kann ich ja eigentlich auch nichts dagegen tun, ja.
Ja, der kann.
So, wir sind fertig.
Komplett.
Bam.
Danach kann man das PSSH einloggen.
Gut.
Vielleicht hätte ich dem Ding mal eine feste IP geben sollen.
Das ist overrated.
Komplett overrated.
Guck ich halt bei mir im PFSense nach, was es für eine IP gekriegt hat.
Aber erst einmal noch Passwort eintippen.
Deededeedee.
Elgato.
Wo ist da...
Alter.
Risikomische Capture Card, Ey.
Da musst du immer das Kabel rein und raus machen.
Das kann's doch nicht sein.
So.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Ganz komisch, ey.
Ey.
Unlock, jaja.
Unlock Coggers.
Wir unlocken Coggers.
Das ist das erste, was wir machen müssen.
Dass wir über SSH den Rechner unlocken können.
Weil ich habe keinen Bock, mich jedes Mal an den Rechner dran zu stöpseln.
Okay, nice.
Wir gucken nochmal kurz, was wir für eine IP gekriegt haben, wenn wir schon gerade da sind.
IP Add, wir nehmen auch das Neue.
Auch wenn ich immer noch so über die Jahre an ifconfig gewöhnt bin.
Irgendwie, tja, weiß nicht.
Muss ich mich da langsam mal dran gewöhnen.
So, switchen wir mal zurück.
Und gehen in unsere VM.
Und stöpseln die Tastatur mal wieder ab.
Und loggen uns dann PSSH drauf ein.
In der Hoffnung, dass ich jetzt nichts runterschmeiße.
Und ich muss unbedingt mal nachgucken, warum meine Tastatur zwei USB-Anschlüsse hat.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Das müssen wir jetzt gerade mal nachgucken.
Warum hat die zwei USB-Anschlüsse?
Ähm, ja, verstehe ich noch nicht.
Warum hat die?
Ja, zwei USB-Anschlüsse.
Why two USB-Anschlüsse?
Genau das frage ich mich auch gerade.
Ja, zwei USB-Anschlüsse.
Ach so, die Tastatur hat noch eine USB, die man da drüber...
Ah.
Wer benutzt denn sowas?
Das zweite Kabel ist einfach nur durchgeschleiftes USB.
Ist ja langweilig.
So, add...
Ja.
Super Secret Password.
Max-Add-Commerce am Start.
So, erst mal Update machen.
Und danach stellen wir ein, dass wir anlocken können per SSH.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste.
Habe ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht.
Vergesse ich jedes Mal, wie es funktioniert.
Aber ist nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Da brauchen wir einen SSH-Server, der startet.
Wer?
Wir booten.
Und dann geben wir dann per SSH das Passwort ein und booten weiter.
Schauen wir gleich.
Äh...
Update...
Tastatur!
Please!
Äh...
Hallo Max, machst du mal ein Video über deine Shortcuts?
Wie du zwischen deinen Maschinen wechselst und so weiter.
Und wie du das setzt.
Würde mich halt sehr interessieren, da ich diesen tollen Workflow unter die...
...bekommen.
Äh...
Du meinst...
Du meinst das hier?
Auf Windows und dann auf Linux?
Auf Windows?
Äh...
Das ist relativ simpel gesagt.
Also du kannst ja...
Du kannst ja unter Windows kannst du ja die Desktop switchen mit...
Äh...
Control, Windows-Taste und Pfeiltasten.
Kannst du Desktop switchen.
Und das kannst du dir dann einfach...
Ich habe mir das als Makro gelegt.
Ich weiß, dass ich Update eingetippt habe.
Das ist...
Das war schon Absicht.
Achso, und dann hast du einfach noch vor allem ein Vollbild.
Äh...
Ich kann dir das Makro mal zeigen.
Das ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Das ist das Makro.
Ähm...
Also...
Auf meiner Haupt...
Das ist das Makro, was wir letztens im Stream gemacht haben.
Ähm...
Kakosa-Software.
Äh...
Bei mir auf dem...
Bei meinem...
Arbeits...
Äh...
Account habe ich es auf der Maus...
Habe ich es auf der mittleren Maustaste...
...über den Logitech-Treiber gemacht.
Äh...
Und zwar...
Ja...
Im Prinzip macht das Makro genau das.
Das drückt...
Äh...
Left...
Steuerung Windows-Taste rechts.
Äh...
Und dann macht es noch was ganz Praktisches.
Dann drückt 1 und V und geht auf Exclusive-Mode.
Dass ich hier nicht Probleme habe, wenn ich am Rand irgendwie rumfuddle.
So.
Und dann habe ich auf G2 einfach wieder den...
Äh...
Auf 1 wieder das Makro, um auf Windows zurückzugehen.
Das kannst du aber auch auf deine Logitech-Maus legen.
Ist kein Problem.
Oder aber, wenn du keine programmierbare Maus oder Tastatur hast, machst du einfach Steuerung,
Windows-Taste und rechte.
Ding.
Da musst du halt noch einmal reinklicken danach, dass es wieder funktioniert.
Und das hier ist einfach nur vor allem im Vollbild.
Genau.
Äh...
Gibt es einen Grund, warum du Windows benutzt und darauf Linux in der VRM vorhanden war aus Interesse?
Ähm...
Weil die anderen Sachen, die ich mache, halt Windows brauchen.
Also ich mache auf der...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich mache YouTube-Videos.
Ich habe jetzt in letzter Zeit wenig YouTube-Videos gemacht.
Aber normalerweise mache ich YouTube-Videos.
Und ähm...
Audio-Video-Zeug und vor allem halt von Games.
Das kannst du halt unter Linux nicht machen.
Nachdem ich aber die anderen Sachen viel lieber unter Linux mache,
ist die einfachere Variante, Linux unter Windows zu laufen, zu bekommen,
als alles andere, was ich von Windows brauche, unter Linux.
Das ist einfach die einfache...
So rum ist einfacher.
So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie das funktioniert hat.
Also, wenn man seinen Server anlocken möchte,
beim Booten über SSH, weil immer ist ja sinnvoll, ne?
Wenn man sich überlegt, man hat die Festplatte,
die Festplatte verschlüsselt und den Server irgendwo stehen, ja?
Sei es nur im Keller, also irgendwo, wo man nicht hinlaufen möchte.
Und man startet den neu.
Dann ist es ja so, dass man beim Starten immer das Passwort eingeben muss,
zum Festplatten entschlüsseln, weil sonst kann man nicht booten.
Und man kann das Ganze auch per SSH machen.
Dazu muss man sich einen minimalen SSH-Server installieren,
der quasi beim Booten schon gestartet wird,
auf den man dann das Passwort eintippt.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel, wenn man weiß, wie es geht.
Und ich vergesse...
Ich vergesse, dass jedes Mal, wie es funktioniert.
Und danach stelle ich fest, eigentlich war es total einfach.
Also, eigentlich, it's, it's a F.
Ich versuche, dass wir DropBeer installieren müssen.
Drop, DropBeer.
Bear, DropBeer.
Für...
SSH beim Booten.
So.
Hoggas ist installiert.
Mach mal zu.
So, und jetzt müssen wir, glaube ich...
DropBeer?
Ja, Steinex.
Irgendwie so.
Das ist, das ist ziemlich simpel gewesen.
Äh, install DropBeerInit.
Ja, das da müssen wir installieren.
Und ich glaube fast, das war's mehr oder weniger.
Es war wirklich nicht schwierig.
Danach, genau, danach muss man auch irgendwo einstellen, dass es, ähm...
Invalid...
Ach nee, wir müssen erst...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Nee, wir müssen, wir müssen erst noch irgendwo
ein ordentliches Authorized Keyfile hinschieben.
Auch okay.
Machen wir.
Machen wir alles.
Äh, DropBeer ist ein Mini-SSH-Server, den man beim Booten schon starten kann.
Über den man dann seine Festplatte anlocken kann, um weiter zu booten.
So, und das erste, was wir jetzt machen, ist, wir locken uns nochmal aus.
Und sagen, äh, SSH Copy ID.
Dass wir uns da jetzt ohne Passwort einloggen können.
Das ist wichtig.
Ups.
Ja, ja, man...
Ich wollte das eigentlich überhaupt nicht drücken, so.
Okay, er löst aber nicht den eigentlichen SSH-Server ab, sondern nur beim Boot, richtig.
Ähm, das muss...
Ich glaube, man musste das sogar einstellen, dass der...
Dass der sich beendet irgendwie danach.
So, wo war das jetzt?
etc.defaults.drop?
Nee.
etc.drop.beer.
Hier, da.
Config.
Da muss man auch IP und so einstellen irgendwo.
Aber ich muss mal nachschauen.
Ich muss mal nachschauen.
Da muss man...
Ich muss mal grad mal irgendeinen Guide angucken.
Ich vergesse...
Wie gesagt, ich vergesse jedes Mal, wie das wiederkrempeln funktioniert.
So, ein Authorized Key können wir eigentlich aber hinkopieren aus meinem Heimatverzeichnis.
Dass das...
Mal gucken, ob das dann so funktioniert.
Da ist dann mein Key drinne.
Guck mal, gibt's bestimmt einen Guide für...
Ich warte schon 10 Monate auf das Antivirus-Video.
Hab ich nicht ein Antivirus-Video gemacht?
Hab ich doch.
Hier, da.
Guck mal.
Waren die Jungs schon editiert?
Wie?
Antiviren-Software noch sinnvoll oder sogar gefährlich?
Hab ich gesagt, dass ich noch was dazu...
Echt?
Hehehe.
Äh, was wollte ich denn noch dazu sagen?
Ja, Buzzybox brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, dass wir eine Shell haben beim Einladen.
Ah, etc.defaults.drop.beer sollen wir editieren?
Machen wir.
Windows Defender plus U-Block.
Hab ich mittlerweile auch.
Ja.
Ja, genau, Steinex.
Im Prinzip schon.
Dass sowas in der Richtung kam, war im Endeffekt auch raus bei dem Video.
Gerade wenn Antivirus, kann man bei Windows Defender bleiben.
Zusätzlichen Kram installieren muss man nicht.
Und ob man es wirklich braucht, ist eh fragwürdig.
Andere Betriebssysteme oder Smartphone?
Ah, da könnte ich wirklich mal was zu sagen.
Auf dem Smartphone bin ich mittlerweile unschlüssig, ob man sowas braucht.
Also, ich glaube, dass ich das jetzt nicht mehr so gut kann.
Also, ursprünglich hätte ich immer gesagt, braucht man nicht.
Totaler Blödsinn.
Aber nachdem es immer mehr Smartphone-Dinger gibt, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob man das braucht oder nicht.
Ich tendiere aber eher zu, nein, braucht man nicht.
Achso, ja, immer.
Das Wichtigste, was man zuerst auf jedem Linux-System installiert, ist ein ordentlicher WIM.
Dass man sich nicht mit diesem Krempli rumschlagen muss.
Dass man schon WIM vorinstalliert hat.
Okay, man installiert einen WIM und man installiert einen T-Max.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Das braucht man.
Ohne.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind.
Die Ubuntu-Standard-Installation, Ubuntu-Server ist ziemlich gut.
Ist alles drin, was man braucht.
Ja, und eine Sache, die ich auch noch ganz gerne installiere, ist das hier.
Das, ähm, ist, mal angenommen, man, man,
Also wirklich was, wo man sagen würde, hey, das Ding hat wenig Kerne, dafür ultra hoch getaktet, fällt mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nichts ein.
Ich meine, in der Regel kannst du sagen, umso mehr Kerne, umso niedriger ist der einzelne Kern.
Aber, ich, ich, ich denke mal, mit dem aktuellsten Desktop-CPU fährst du da wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber ansonsten gibt es wahrscheinlich auch irgendeine Jig Xeons oder so, aber das Zeug ist immer so ultra teuer.
Du brauchst extra Kühler, extra Boards, extra, extra alles irgendwie.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt, war das jetzt alles, was man machen musste?
Das muss, das musste, hallo?
Ich kann, ich darf nicht mehr tippen in meiner VM.
Okay, jetzt darf ich wieder tippen.
Das, das habe ich auch noch nie gemacht.
Okay.
So, mal, schon viel zu, wobei, ich bilde mir ein, dass das, ähm, den genau Splash haben wir noch gar nicht.
Ich glaube, das hast du, boah, ich glaube, das musst du nur auf dem Desktop machen.
Crap updaten müssen wir eigentlich auch nicht, weil ich meine, wir haben ja im Endeffekt nichts gemacht.
Reboot.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Haben wir, haben wir Init-Dings geupdatet? Ja, haben wir.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir jetzt beim Booten...
Anloggen können.
Ich switch, ich, ich switch gleich wieder rüber auf die, auf die Elgator.
Guck, das Schöne an T-Max ist jetzt, ich kann jetzt auch einfach ein zweites, ein zweites Tab aufmachen.
Mich auf dem gleichen System nochmal einloggen.
Und hier unten gucken, wo eigentlich die Auslastung verursacht wird.
Also, das ist schon praktisch, ja.
Oder halt ein T-Max auf dem System stand.
So, wir rebooten mal.
Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt nichts, nichts vergessen.
Wenn nicht, muss ich nochmal die Tastatur anstöpseln.
Ähm, genau, ich muss den, äh, den Namen eingeben.
Verbrechner, Kogas, Reboot, bam.
So, und jetzt gehen wir rüber.
Und schalten nochmal auf die Elgator.
Und hoffen, die Elgator, Elgatort, so vor sich hin.
Wow.
Ach, Elgator, warum verlierst du denn immer da einen?
Macht's, macht's nicht, ne?
Aha, aha.
Funktioniert, guck mal.
Starting Job, ja.
Adress 2157.
Oh, ne, ich glaube, wir haben vergessen, den Key hinzuzufügen, oder?
Ha, ne, haben wir nicht.
Haha, haben wir nicht.
Ja, passt.
Guck, und jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich.
Jetzt bin ich eingeloggt, ähm, jetzt bin ich eingeloggt quasi in so einem Minimalsystem, wo ich nichts anderes großartig machen kann, außer halt meine Platte zu anloggen.
Zack.
Und jetzt, sehen wir, jetzt ist es abgekackt hier an der Stelle.
Und wenn ich jetzt wieder umschalte, sehen wir auch, er bootet weiter.
Zack, ist gebootet.
Eats.
Der, warum läuft denn der noch?
Das lässt sich noch optimieren.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht so schön.
Hm.
Na gut.
Das soll, deswegen sollte man wahrscheinlich sein.
Sam.
Ja, ja, ja, mach ich, mach ich alles noch.
Was, auf Null?
Ne, in der, ne, das musste man auf Null stellen, dass er überhaupt startet beim Booten.
Äh.
Ach so.
Ah, Moment.
Moment.
Ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich.
Ich, ich, ich, ich, ich.
Bezieht sich das jetzt auf...
Ne, oder?
Bezieht, ich dachte, das bezieht sich aufs, aufs Booten.
Gucken wir mal, ob er jetzt meckert.
Willst du dich jetzt beschweren, dass du kein Geld ausgeben darfst, Knärbär, oder wie?
Muss ich, muss ich mich jetzt rechtfertigen dafür, dass du mir nicht dein Geld geben darfst, oder wie?
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Hallo, Ronix.
Knärbär auszulöscht.
Ja gut, dann muss ich mich ja wohl drum kümmern.
Okay, und jetzt ist halt die Frage, startet das jetzt noch?
Nee, nee, man muss das schon da reinschreiben.
Oder? Ich bin... Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich meine, wir könnten dem Ding wirklich einen anderen Port geben.
Egal, ich meine, wir brauchen es ja nur... Das ist ja nicht wild.
Wir brauchen es ja nur beim Neustarten.
So, äh, hallo, I'm Chisutz.
Ähm, okay, also das funktioniert jetzt prinzipiell.
Ich kann das Ding anlocken beim Starten, das ist schon mal das Wichtigste.
So, okay, jetzt können wir zur eigentlichen Sache kommen.
Wir haben ein verschlüsseltes System am Start mit 500G Platte.
Gucken wir mal, was es Updates gibt, aber das haben wir eben schon gemacht.
Sollte jetzt nicht... Nee, soll jetzt wirklich nichts mehr geben.
So, das kann man eben verschlüsselt, ähm...
Oh, Donation.
Eine Donation.
Der Sibaro hat donatet.
Eine 50... Alter, Sibaro, was ist los?
Weihnachtsgeld zu null, alter Name.
Vogels.
Dazu kann ich bloß noch sagen, hier...
Easy. Easy.
Nice, Sibaro.
Wie gesagt, ihr müsst ja alle nichts donaten, wenn ihr nicht wollt.
Aber wenn ihr wollt, dann habe ich natürlich auch nichts dagegen.
Und wenn ihr mich subbt, wenn ich irgendwann mal einen Sub-Button habe, wäre natürlich auch nice.
Ich habe ja noch 5 Tage Zeit, 6 Tage Zeit, mich darum zu kümmern dieses Jahr.
Vielleicht mache ich das ja auch.
So, ähm, weiter im Text.
Also die grundsätzliche Sache funktioniert schon mal.
Ähm, wir haben eingerichtet, dass wir nicht einfach aus Versehen rebooten können.
Jetzt hauen wir mal ein T-Max rein.
So, und jetzt ist die Frage, jetzt geht es ja eigentlich darum, was wir machen.
Jetzt ist bloß die Frage...
Was, ähm...
Wie, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also ich brauche da auf jeden Fall, also einen NGINX brauche ich auf jeden Fall drauf.
Ähm...
Warte mal, ich muss mal was googeln.
So, einen NGINX brauche ich auf jeden Fall drauf.
Will mehr Emotes.
Mach jetzt...
Selbst wenn ich es jetzt machen würde, wo soll ich denn Emotes herkriegen?
Da muss ich mir erstmal irgendeinen Designer suchen.
Die gefühlt alle recht unzuverlässig sind.
Ähm...
Einen raussuchen, der ordentliche Emotes machen kann.
Dann mich mit dem einig werden, so Money-technisch.
Ich will erster sein.
Ja, ich mach's ja schon.
Ihr dürft mir alle bald euer Geld geben.
Ich will ja mal nicht so sein.
Und dann machen wir Keks-Emotes und Easy-Keks-Emotes und...
Katz-FPS-Emotes und...
Mautz-FPS-Emotes und alles, ja.
NGINX müssen wir installieren, weil Web-Server brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Kommen wir nicht drumherum.
So, wo ich...
Ich bin mir jetzt echt unschlüssig, wie ich das Ganze...
Wie ich das Ganze machen soll.
Installiere ich den ganzen Krempel einfach direkt auf den Server drauf?
Mach ich LXT-Container oder mach ich...
Für Home Assistant Docker-Stellz?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht, was ich am besten mache.
Weil...
Eigentlich will ich es ja einfacher machen als aktuell.
Ich glaube, wir machen LXT-Container mit...
Ach, das ist aber auch doof.
Den Scheiß musst du dann wieder updaten.
Wir installieren alles auf das System drauf.
Hast einen Server daheim?
Ja, nicht nur einen.
Das ist gerade die Ablöse für den Fetten.
Das ist gerade die Ablöse für den Fetten, den wir installieren.
Ach so, ja, stimmt.
Nö, nö, nö.
Eine Sache, die ganz nützlich ist, die bei Ubuntu auch dabei ist,
ist das Dings hier.
Ist das so?
Ne, warte mal.
Wie hieß das Kram?
Prompt?
Der, der...
Die haben so einen Prompt dabei, der standardmäßig Temperatur und sowas anzeigt.
Das war nicht Pure Prompt.
Das war...
Ähm...
Wie ist denn der Mist jetzt nochmal?
Le...
Prompt?
Ja, der war da.
Das ist so.
Finde ich ganz brav.
Weißt du, ich nehme immer...
Ich nehme immer ganz gern Zeug, was schon dabei ist.
Irgendwie spackt meine VM, wenn ich drinnen rumklicke.
Da habe ich manchmal nicht.
Irgendwas mit Container und Stelzen.
Äh, was?
Wofür ich die benutze?
Äh...
Heimatomatisierungszeug, Fernsehzeug.
Ich habe es am Anfang noch gezeigt.
Ähm...
Hier hast du einmal meine...
Das ist meine KVM-VMs.
Ups, falsche Kiste.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut.
Äh...
OpenSense.
Netzwerkgedöns.
Ähm...
Dann eine Heimatomatisierungs-VM.
Dann habe ich...
Ähm...
Dann habe ich hier jede Menge Containers drauflaufen für alle möglichen Dinger.
Und, ähm...
Auf...
Meine Heimatomatisierungskiste...
habe ich...
noch Docker-Gedöns laufen.
So, und das ist mir einfach viel zu komplex.
Und viel zu Single-Point-of-Failure.
Für...
Mein Zeug, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, das Ding war relativ teuer.
Aber es war halt selbst konstruiert.
Ja, selbst gebaut.
Sieht man ja hier im Bit.
Da ist aber auch komplett Oversize das Teil.
Das ist so mein Mini-Rack.
Mit dem 10G-Switch unten drunter.
Und hier oben ist halt...
Sieht man, kann man reingucken.
Also das war halt relativ teuer.
Und es ist halt komplett Oversize.
Deswegen...
Da hast du 2x...
Äh...
3x 10TB.
Und das ist halt...
3x 10TB-Platten drinnen.
Und 8-Kern-Xeon.
Ähm...
10G-Anschlüsse.
Ich glaube...
48G-RAM.
Äh...
Nen...
Nen Dings...
SAS.
Äh...
Adapter.
Gedöns.
Es ist einfach komplett Oversize für mich.
Gibt es dann auch ein neues Video, wenn du alles gebaut hast?
Das könnte man tatsächlich machen.
Die Namen der NXC-Container.
Ja.
Ja, was meinst du, warum das neue System Kogas heißt?
Ja, und das Ziel ist, das fette 4HE-System abzulösen durch 3 kleinere Sachen.
Die erstens weniger Strom verbrauchen und zweitens nicht mehr so Single-Point-of-Failure-mäßig sind.
Da kommt ein Mikrotech-Router hin.
Da kommt jetzt die Kiste, die wir installieren für Heimatomatisierung, Fernseh- und alles, was ein bisschen Rechenleistung braucht.
Und...
Dann so ein Single-Board-Computer mit 10T-Platte.
Für...
Backups.
Wie virtualisierst du verschiedene Server?
Ich hab doch gerade gesagt, die paar sind mit KVM, die anderen sind mit LXC und Heimatomatisierungsteilchen sind mit Docker.
Das ist auch viel zu kompliziert.
Viel zu kompliziert.
Ähm...
So, wie mach ich denn das jetzt?
Ich bin unschlüssig.
Ähm...
Mach ich die Docker-Instanz?
Installation von Home Assistant?
Oder mach ich...
...eine LXC-Kiste?
Oder knall ich's einfach auf den Server selbst drauf?
Kannst du kurz Docker erklären?
Ja, also...
Um Docker zu erklären...
Also, erstens bin ich nicht der großartige Docker-Fachmann, das muss man auch schon dabei sagen.
Ähm...
Also, das muss man wissen, was Linux-Container sind.
Im Prinzip ist ein Linux-Container...
...nix anderes wie ein 0815-Prozess, den du auf deinem Linux-System startest.
Also, sprich, zwischen einem HATOP, was du ausführst, und einem HATOP im Container ist erstmal kein Unterschied.
Das sind beides ganz normale HATOP-Prozesse.
Der Unterschied ist, dass, ähm, wenn du einen Container startest mit HATOP drin,
das HATOP ein bisschen abgeschottet ist mit extra Namespaces und mit, äh...
Erster Kram...
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Wie heißt es?
C-Groups, C-Groups, ja.
Ähm...
Das heißt, du hast so ein paar Sachen wie Hostname, Netzwerk-Access, Disk-IO und sowas in der Richtung,
ist quasi gefiltert, und du kannst ein paar Sachen in einem Container nicht machen.
Was du zum Beispiel in einem Container nicht machen kannst, sind Kernel-Module laden.
Das wäre nämlich auch ein bisschen scheiße, wenn du aus einem Container Kernel-Module laden könntest.
Du hast da keinen Zugriff aus dem Container draus.
Das führt natürlich dazu, dass die Dinger ein bisschen besser isoliert voneinander laufen.
Allerdings, dadurch, dass es nachher...
Nach wie vor ein ganz normaler Prozess ist auf deiner Linux-Kiste, so wie alles andere auch,
sind Container relativ schnell.
Also im Prinzip hast du überhaupt keinen Unterschied zwischen...
So gut wie keinen...
Eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied zwischen einem Prozess, den du bei dir auf dem Host-System startest,
oder einem Prozess, den du quasi auf deinem Host-System startest, mit noch ein bisschen Container-Zeug drumherum.
Das heißt, so viel Unterschied zu einem normalen Prozess ist ein Container nicht.
So, und das ist alles LXC.
Ist wohlgemerkt, dass die Container-Geschichte im Kernel nennt sich LXC.
Und das verwenden alle Containerisierungs-Geschichten.
Es verwenden alle das Gleiche.
Es verwenden alle LXC im Kernel.
Docker macht keine Container.
LXD macht auch keine Container.
Was gibt es denn da noch so alles?
Ranger und hast du nicht gesehen?
Sie machen alle keine Container.
Die verwenden alle Namespaces, C-Groups und das Geduldens, was im Kernel drin ist.
So, und was Docker jetzt macht, ist einen Weg, quasi den Container-Erstellungsprozess zu vereinheitlichen und zu automatisieren.
Also Docker ist quasi ein User-Interface für die Container-Funktion im Kernel.
Und das ist auch nicht das Einzige.
Docker ist aber mit Abstand das bekannteste und verbreitetste.
Das heißt, man nutzt quasi...
Man nutzt quasi, um verschiedene Dinge ein bisschen besser voneinander zu trennen.
Ja, wobei der hauptsächliche Charme von Docker ist,
diese Sache mit, dass die Sachen voneinander getrennt laufen, ist sicherlich auch ein Punkt.
Aber der hauptsächliche Charme von Docker, und das ist auch das, wo es herkommt,
wo es heute leider ein bisschen zu anderen Dingern missbraucht wird,
der Charme von Docker und die ursprüngliche Idee hinter Docker war,
dass du, wenn du Sachen entwickelst und es testen möchtest,
dass du dann relativ schnell dir ein Testsystem starten können willst,
was nach Möglichkeiten die Sachen installiert hat, die deine Produktivsysteme auch installiert haben
oder installiert haben werden.
Oder im besten Fall lässt du einfach den gleichen Container auf deinen Produktionsservern laufen.
Wobei dafür ist es eigentlich nie gedacht gewesen, auch wenn man das heute mittlerweile macht.
Aber eigentlich ist es dafür nie gedacht gewesen.
Es ist gedacht für Entwicklersysteme,
die man sich schnell spawnen kann, um darauf was auszuprobieren im Endeffekt.
Und wo alle Sachen, die du als Abhängigkeiten hast für deine Anwendung mit dabei sind.
Das ist eigentlich der große Pluspunkt von Docker.
Also sprich, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel hier,
du kennst, sag mal, warum kann ich denn hier nicht klicken?
Warum muss ich jetzt immer rein und raus switchen?
Was ist das für ein Müll?
Geh da ein bisschen mit Docker.
Ja, ich hoffe, ihr kennt den hier nicht.
Wenn ich den Duck hab, den Docker hab,
so, da kannst du jetzt zum Beispiel mal suchen nach irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Samba-Server oder so.
Und da findest du zig vorgefertigte Samba-Container.
Aber es sind eigentlich gar keine Container,
weil alles, was das ist auf Docker-Hub,
sind im Prinzip Config-Files, wie dein Docker den Container bei dir lokal dann erstellt.
Alter!
Ja, ich mach das ja.
Ich mach, ich war aber kein Affiliate, ich schreib Twitch an.
Ja, genau.
Und wie du hier siehst,
im Prinzip ist das, auch wenn man sagt, so quasi auf Docker-Hub gibt's Container, das stimmt gar nicht.
Auf Docker-Hub gibt's Docker-Files,
wo dann drinnen steht,
wie so ein Container erstellt wird.
Also im Prinzip steht da so was drinnen wie FromAlpine,
also sprich, die nehmen als Base,
Base-ISO, nehmen die so ein Alpine-Image,
das ist ein relativ Light-Wide,
Linux.
Wohl, wohlgemerkt, auch wenn da drinnen steht, FromAlpine,
es ist kein Alpine-Linux.
Spricht man das überhaupt so aus?
Es ist kein Alpine-Linux, was läuft.
Es läuft weiterhin in Ubuntu mit dem gleichen Kernel.
Also sprich,
es läuft alles auf diesem Kernel
und im Prinzip, wie wenn du den Prozess einfach so starten würdest,
das einzige, was sie von Alpine verwenden, ist...
Was ist denn jetzt?
Das einzige, was der Dude von Alpine verwendet, ist,
halt die Umgebung, also sprich die Libraries, die dabei sind
und alles wirkliche.
Nicht den Kernel, weil das ist ja keine richtige VM.
So, und dann macht er hier gedöhnt und am Ende startet Docker und ist da.
Also Docker ist quasi so ein schöner Weg,
sich erstens Entwicklersysteme schnell hinzustellen,
die halt auch immer gleich sind.
Du könntest zum Beispiel sagen, hey, wir bauen uns,
wir entwickeln jetzt eine tolle Videokonferenz-Software
und die wollen wir, während wir die entwickeln,
wollen wir die testen.
Und das heißt, wir bauen uns mal so einen Docker-File,
was quasi so ungefähr ähnlich ist unserer Produktivsysteme
und die kann dann jeder Entwickler verwenden,
um die Anwendung zu testen.
Sprich, dann hast du auch nicht mehr das Phänomen,
dass die Anwendung bei dir auf dem Rechner funktioniert
und beim nächsten nicht
und auf deinem Produktiv-Server erst recht nicht.
Und dafür ist Docker eigentlich ursprünglich gedacht.
Was da heute mittlerweile daraus gemacht wurde,
wo Docker natürlich auch mitgeholfen hat,
weil ich meine, ihr habt den Bedarf da schon erkannt irgendwie,
ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Und wo viele Leute mit Docker in Berührung kommen,
ist allerdings gar nicht mehr so bei der ursprünglichen Sache,
also nach dem Motto, wir bauen uns ein paar Testdinger
für schnelle Entwicklersysteme,
die wir schnell starten können und wieder wegwerfen können,
weil, wie gesagt, so ein Container starten dauert nicht länger,
wie den Befehl so zu starten, minimal länger.
Die meisten Leute kommen dann,
die meisten Leute kommen heutzutage mit Docker in Berührung,
wenn sie irgendwelche Anwendungen installieren,
eben als Docker-Container.
Also sprich, zum Beispiel Home Assistant hat einen fertigen Docker-Container.
Wenn ich Home Assistant installieren will,
das ist eine Heimautomatisierungslösung, die ich verwende,
dann kann ich das einfach mit Docker machen
und dadurch, dass die quasi dieses Docker-File bereitstellen,
starte ich bei mir einen Container,
wo quasi anhand ihres Docker-Files dann auch alles hochgefahren wird,
so und bzw. alle Libraries dabei sind, die es braucht
und das ist halt relativ easy für mich.
Aber es hat auch ein paar Steine im Weg, ja.
Also wenn man, wenn man jetzt,
wenn man sich beispielsweise einen Docker-Container startet,
um darin quasi nicht einfach nur eine Anwendung zu testen,
die man selbst entwickelt oder irgendwas Fertiges zu installieren,
sondern noch rumbasteln muss,
weil man noch gar nicht so genau weiß,
wie man das System konfigurieren muss,
dass die Anwendung funktioniert,
dann ist Docker sehr nervig,
weil Docker ist kein gutes Live-System.
Also du kannst jetzt,
du kannst zwar in einem Docker quasi einen Innent starten
und hast dann da halt auch im Zweifelsfall eine Bash oder eine Shell irgendwie drinne,
aber das ist so nicht gedacht.
Du musst dann quasi auch immer wieder committen,
dann musst du stoppen.
Das ist eher gedacht,
du hast ein Docker-File,
das beschreibt, wie das System am Ende aussehen soll,
du startest es und gut.
Auf meiner, dafür verwenden es die meisten Leute, ja, mittlerweile.
Das Schöne ist, du kannst,
du kannst halt auch relativ einfach Snapshots machen, ja,
und wenn ein Upgrade in die Hose geht,
kannst du relativ einfach wieder downgraden.
Wobei ich finde,
das ist teilweise ein bisschen kompliziert,
wofür es sich halt gar nicht eignet ist,
wenn du quasi ein Bastel-System haben möchtest.
Also sagen wir mal,
ich habe jetzt hier meinen Linux-Server, ne.
Sag mal, warum kann ich denn hier nicht reinklicken?
Immer, was ist das denn?
Läuft da irgendwas im Hintergrund?
Was ist das?
The fuck?
So.
Ähm.
Wo war ich denn jetzt gerade dabei?
Genau.
Ähm.
Wofür es sich halt gar nicht eignet ist,
wenn du ein Bastel-System haben willst.
Also sprich,
ich habe hier jetzt meinen Server
und will jetzt da drauf irgendwas ausprobieren
und ich weiß noch gar nicht,
ob ich das haben will,
ich weiß nicht so genau,
wie es funktioniert
und ich will einfach ein bisschen rumspielen.
Das heißt,
ich will ein System haben,
das, ähm,
das einfach mal da ist,
auf dem ich was ausprobieren kann
und wenn es nicht mehr will,
oder wenn ich es nicht mehr will,
will ich es einfach rückstandslos wegwerfen können.
Also mit dem rückstandslos wegwerfen funktioniert bei Docker,
aber das live daran rumspielen funktioniert nicht wirklich gut.
Dafür gibt es dann andere Sachen.
Dann hast du sowas wie LXC zum Beispiel.
Ja,
wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel mein,
ähm,
hier habe ich bei mir lokal einen LXC-Container
mit Home Assistant und Gedöns drauf.
Das ist quasi
ein ganz normales,
vollwertiges,
äh,
Linux-System,
auf dem ich alles mögliche machen kann,
was ich will.
Und wenn ich nicht mehr will,
kann ich ihn auch wegwerfen.
Also für vollständige,
äh,
so Bastelumgebung ist LXC,
beziehungsweise LXD ist es eigentlich,
ähm,
die Ubuntu-Variante,
ist viel besser geeignet als Docker.
Docker ist wirklich nur sinnvoll,
Anwendung starten und gut ist.
All der Care ist jetzt gut.
Übertreib's mal nicht,
äh.
Ich mach's ja.
So,
ähm,
wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Ja, aber,
äh,
Masino 25 Kubernetes ist für daheim vollkommen
beknackt.
Ähm,
wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Genau,
also wir haben einen Nginx installiert,
den brauch ich auf jeden Fall,
wenn du Diverse-Proxy stellst,
ähm,
ja,
und jetzt hab ich mich gefragt,
wie installiere ich meinen Kram drauf.
Ich,
ich tendiere dazu,
dass ich auf diesen ganzen Docker-Kram
und ganzen LXC-Kram auf meinem System jetzt scheiße,
weil's das einfach zu komplex macht,
und mir meinen Home Assistant und,
ähm,
das brauch ich sonst noch,
eigentlich nur Home Assistant,
Home Assistant und,
und den TV-Server,
den installier ich mir einfach auf der Kiste drauf.
Wollen wir mal einen Benchmark machen,
und gucken,
wie schnell die Kiste ist.
Ich mein,
das ist,
hat immerhin vier Kerne,
und ist ein,
ist ein Celeron mit 1,5G,
ja,
kickass.
Wir installieren noch Sensors,
dass wir gucken können,
äh,
wie hieß der Kram?
LM-Sensor?
Ja,
ja.
Wir installieren mal Sensors und gucken mal,
wie,
äh,
wie warm,
wie warm das Ding wird.
Sensors.
Okay,
es ist nicht warm.
Es ist,
es ist,
das Ding ist passiv gekühlt,
ne?
Das Ding ist passiv gekühlt.
So,
jetzt sieht man wieder,
was praktisch an T-Max ist.
Watch Sensors.
Watch führt jede Sekunde das,
das Kommando neu aus.
Ähm,
jetzt sehen wir mal,
wie warm das System wird.
So,
jetzt machen wir mal irgendwie was.
komm,
wir machen mal,
wir machen mal ein bisschen Last.
Wir machen das,
wir machen das kein Benchmark,
wir machen das ein bisschen Last.
Zwo hoch,
bla bla bla.
Sollen wir mal BC ausrechnen.
Bam.
So,
und da unten drunter machen wir nochmal einen Top,
dass wir sehen,
dass das Ding auch was macht.
Ein Kern ist komplett ausgelastet
und es wird schon ein bisschen wärmer.
Okay.
Starten,
starten wir das mal dreimal,
hä?
Starten wir mal dreimal
und gucken mal,
wie warm es wird.
So,
drei Kerne voll ausgelastet,
was ja auch sinnvoll ist,
bei dreimal rechnen,
ne?
Wie warm,
mal gucken,
wie warm das,
wie warm der Rechner wird.
Mit was,
mit was ich da so im Sommer
in meinem nicht belüfteten,
äh,
Abstell-Server,
Serverraum mit rechnen kann.
Komm,
wisst ihr was?
Wir starten nochmal ein.
Eats.
Oh,
jetzt wird das System schon langsam unresponsive.
So.
Jetzt lassen wir es mal kurz laufen,
ich geh mal kurz pinkeln.
Ich überhitze das Ding nicht.
Wie gesagt,
ist noch passiv gekühlt,
so ein,
so ein Quadcore,
passiv gekühlt,
volle Last,
ich weiß ja nicht.
So.
Wieder am Start
und ist schon überhitzt,
nur wird gar nicht wirklich warm,
ne?
So,
jetzt wird gar nicht wirklich warm,
ne?
Was gab es denn bei euch eigentlich
zu Weihnachten zu essen?
Also,
bei uns gab es,
äh,
Re,
so Stückchen,
Re-Gulasch,
denke ich mal.
Also,
von der Konsistenz her.
Ragu,
gab es.
So rum,
genau.
Mit,
äh,
Rotkraut und Semmelknödel.
Krass bei euch dann.
Re-Gulasch bei Nextdoor,
genau.
Pizza,
Pizza.
So,
also ich denke,
oh,
mein Prompt ist da mal und der Rechner ist aber schon ganz schön,
äh,
überlastet.
Deswegen mag ich den Prompt.
Der ist bei Ubuntu dabei
und ist standardmäßig so konfiguriert,
dass er dir alles Wichtige anzeigt.
Und das,
finde ich,
ist wieder das Schöne an Ubuntu Server.
Die haben irgendwie eine sinnvolle Paketauswahl
und eine sinnvolle Vorinstallation.
Also,
kann mich da gar nicht beschweren.
gut.
Ich glaube,
das System wird nicht überwacht.
Also,
gut.
Ich glaube,
das System wird nicht überwacht.
Ich,
ich greife jetzt mal kurz an den Passivkühler dran,
wie warm das Ding ist.
Boah.
Man kann den Finger drauf lassen.
Es wird ein bisschen unangenehm,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so,
nicht so wild.
Also,
ich glaube,
dass das Ding überwacht,
muss ich mir keine Gedanken machen.
Auch im Sommer nicht.
Wie heißt das Paket?
Liquid Prompt.
Gibt's,
gibt's auch auf GitHub.
Was da?
Also,
für andere Systeme.
Kann man sich sagen,
das System ist nicht so gut.
Also,
ich glaube,
das System ist nicht so gut.
Kann man sich Sachen auch konfigurieren.
Aber ich finde es halt einfach ganz praktisch,
weil es bei Ubuntu dabei ist.
Guck,
das zeigt dir auch an,
was du für Prozesse im Hintergrund laufen hast und so.
Gut.
Okay.
Also,
ich würde sagen,
so,
sagen wir mal so,
viel wärmer als 66,
67 Grad oder so,
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht werden.
Dann machen wir mal unsere Taschenrechner wieder aus.
Ja,
No-Skiller,
immer das,
wofür es,
was man braucht.
Ich bin mittlerweile auch drüber hinweg,
dass ich irgendwie so,
sagen wir mal,
so ein bisschen,
so,
Und sagt, Ubuntu-Server ist mir zu fett.
Was der eigentlich ohne Probleme auch mit 256 MB RAM funktioniert.
Also absolut ohne Probleme.
Weil was ist da großartig vorinstalliert drauf, man?
Nichts, was im Hintergrund läuft eigentlich.
Außer den SSH.
Aber wenn einem das zu viel ist, dann nimm mal irgendwas anderes.
Was nimmst du denn für deine VMs dann?
Guck, und hier sieht man übrigens auch schön, wie praktisch T-Max ist.
Hier oben was machen, unten gucken wir uns, wie warm das System wird.
Unten rechts gucken wir uns die Auslastung an.
Ja klar, DBA geht auch.
So, okay, da installiere ich jetzt meinen Home Assistant auch so drauf.
Kennst du dich gut mit Linux aus?
Man könnte sagen, dass ich mein Geld unter anderem mit Linux verdiene.
Zumindest früher verdient habe.
Wie gesagt, mittlerweile ist es mehr Richtung Softwareentwicklung, ohne selbst zu entwickeln.
Sondern mir eher das durchzulesen, was andere entwickelt haben.
Aber ich bin da schon lange dabei.
Äh, okay, Home Assis- Home Assistant-Person-Install, guck mal, wie das funktioniert.
Scheiß auf LXC und Docker und Gedöns.
Ich will's, ich will's simpel, simpel haben.
Haben wir am liebsten Red Hat CentOS?
Ja, auf der Arbeit haben wir auch nur Red Hat CentOS.
Das hat's mir wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen den Spaß da dran ver-verdorben, so.
Ich kann dir gar nicht so genau sagen, warum.
Aber irgendwie finde ich vom Handling, Ubuntu macht mir einfach, Ubuntu Server macht mir einfach Spaß zu benutzen.
Red Hat ist halt einfach nur da.
Kannst du Texteditor empfehlen?
Ja, Visual Studio Code.
Achso, C, C, C++.
Nein, C, C++ würde ich schon anders fänden.
C, C++ würde ich den Qt Creator verwenden, den hier.
Hab ich den installiert?
Qt.
Ja, ja, den würde ich verwenden.
Was ich?
Bla.
Ne, ich erstelle jetzt nix.
Aber der Qt Creator ist gut.
Ich erstelle nochmal was.
Also der Qt Creator ist wirklich gut.
Ah, du hast so die üblichen Sachen.
Die man braucht.
Die Autovervollständigung ist fast so gut wie in Visual Studio.
Also wenn's kostenlos sein soll, ist der Qt Creator wirklich top.
Kostenlos hast du sonst auch noch, ähm, klar, du kannst ja auch, jetzt haut er aber ganz schön in die Tasten, der Gude.
Was geht mit dem?
So.
Du kannst natürlich auch Visual Studio Code so konfigurieren, dass C++ ordentlich funktioniert.
Ähm.
Aber für C++, das ist einfach was, was gut ist und funktioniert.
Würde ich den Qt Creator nehmen.
Der ist wirklich, der taugt.
Ansonsten, wenn du Geld ausgeben kannst, kannst du auch, äh, von JetBrains.
Lion heißt das, glaub ich.
Den ihre.
Hab ich aber selbst noch nicht verwendet.
Den ihre C, C++ Umgebung.
Muss man nicht für Qt zahlen, wenn man das kommerziell verwenden will.
Nein, muss man nicht.
Du musst Qt, du musst dir bloß, glaub ich, den Qt Creator nutzen.
Du musst den Qt Creator nutzen.
Du musst, ähm.
Du musst, mein trading видеospiel in GTB champions 22 überlegen.
Du musst eine kommerzielle Qt-License
einesc-optionalisieren mit Qt.
Du musst den möglichst.
Also...
Ich läfte gleich die TexteschHS,
dann kannst du mit Qt auch kostenpflichtige Anwendungen machen.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade bei Qt sind, wisst ihr, worauf der EA Origin Client basiert?
Na, wenn ich so frage, ist eigentlich relativ klar, ne?
Das ist auch eine, Origin ist auch eine Qt-Anwendung.
Mit Qt Web Engine, also im Prinzip ist der Origin Client übelst das Sammelsurium, ja.
Im Prinzip ist es eine Web-Anwendung, aber drumherum ist Qt mit Qt Web Engine, was selbst wiederum eine Chrome ist.
Oder ne, nicht, Plink? Ne, wie heißt, Plink heißt es jetzt, oder?
Die Engine, ich klicke das jetzt mittlerweile zu hoch, die Dinger, die fast gleich sind, wie die unterschiedlich heißen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, Origin ist Qt mit Qt Web Browser drin und ich vermute mal,
dass es die Overlay-Geschichten und so Sachen...
Ich gehe mal davon aus, es kann auch ein FPS-Counter und sowas.
Sowas ist da natürlich schon native Qt und halt Windows-spezifische Sachen.
Okay, also, wo war man jetzt stehen geblieben?
Ach ja, kennt ihr das übrigens?
Ha, jetzt, Linux Hack of Doom.
Kennen auch die übelsten Linux-Profis manchmal nicht.
Ich kannte den Trick auch noch nicht vor, also ich kenne den auch noch nicht allzu lang.
Übelst nicer Trick.
Und zwar, wenn man jetzt hier so sagt, hier, was weiß ich, ls, ne?
Und dann mache ich History und dann sieht man ja, welche, welche Kommandos ich ausgeführt habe.
So, und mal angenommen, ich will jetzt irgendwas downloaden, was man nicht in der History sehen soll.
Was weiß ich?
Irgendeiner will sich...
Aufnahmen von seiner Lehrerin angucken.
Keine Ahnung, er will nicht das, was er in der History sieht.
Ähm, und...
Normalerweise...
Ah, der, der, der, der Cry, der kennt's.
Normalerweise würde man dann so Sachen machen wie, äh, ja, hier, we get, äh, äh, supergeheim.
So.
Und, ähm, danach würdest du dann quasi in die History gehen.
Äh, äh, ne, was, Bash, Bash History.
Dann würdest du in die History gehen und das quasi wieder löschen und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber!
Viel einfacher.
Man kann einfach...
Guck jetzt, hier ist so, wie ist es drinne.
Äh, man kann einfach...
Noch geheimer.
Man kann einfach Leertaste davor machen.
Und dann taucht es nicht in der History auf.
Was auch die Erklärung dafür ist, was man manchmal hat, dass man schwören könnte, man hat einen Befehl noch ausgeführt, aber er ist nicht in der History drinne.
Das ist, weil man zufällig ein Leerzeichen davor hatte.
Also es kann so und so...
sein.
Aber das ist eine Sache.
Die kennen, die kennen nicht viel.
Ich kannte das auch noch nicht, ich kenne das auch erst seit ein paar Wochen.
Habe ich zufällig in einem Video gesehen, habe ich, also, es gibt manchmal auch gute Videos auf YouTube.
Ansonsten sind die, sind die, sind die meisten Linux und, und, und sonstige Videos, die man so sieht auf YouTube, sind halt ziemlich, äh, ja, schon ziemlich Resident Sleeper, weil, das hast du alle schon gesehen, irgendwie gemacht, aber, ähm, das mit dem Leerzeichen davor kann ich noch nicht.
So.
So, wo, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Äh, Home Assistant haben wir installiert?
Ah, und, wie gesagt, eigentlich wär die, die, die schönere Variante wär, das wirklich jetzt irgendwie mit dem LXC oder dem Docker zu machen, aber ich habe keinen Bock auf die Verwaltung drumherum.
Da weiß ich schon das nächste Mal nicht mehr, wie ich es genau eingerichtet habe.
Was wird gemacht?
Es wird mein 4HE-Single-Point-of-Failure-Super-Server abgelöst durch drei kleine.
Beziehungsweise, durch drei kleine ist zu viel gesagt.
Durch einen kleinen, einen MikroTik-Router und einen Single-Board.
Einen Single-Board-Computer mit Festplatte dran.
Weil zu overkill.
Und zu viel Strom.
Äh, einmal auf deutsch.
Also.
Ich hab aktuell einen fetten Server bei mir stehen.
Den da.
Moment.
Den hier.
Da.
Die fette Kiste.
4 HE, weil 4 HE.
Höhen-Einheiten.
Eine HE, also das kommt nicht vor Head.
Also bei so einem Rack vorne hat man hier immer so ein Ding, also quasi hier wo die Schrauben hinkommen, das ist immer eine Höheneinheit.
So, und der Rechner ist quasi vier Höheneinheiten.
Wenn man Racks kauft, sieht man auch immer dann in der Beschreibung, wie viele Höheneinheiten reinpassen.
Quasi 15 Höheneinheiten oder so, und das ist ein ziemlich kleines Rack.
Genau, drei Schrauben, eine HE.
So ist es richtig.
Und das ist halt eine 4er-E-Kiste, weil ich hab, warum es eine 4er-E-Kiste ist, ist relativ einfach.
Sieht man hier, weil das Netzteil hochkant reinkommt.
Und das Netzteil kommt hochkant rein, weil ich ein besonders, ihr seht ja, der Raum ist nicht sonderlich groß.
Ich glaube, das kann man hier ganz gut erkennen.
Der Raum ist nicht, ich stehe in der Tür, hier ist die Tür, hier.
Also hier ist die Tür.
Also der Raum ist nicht groß.
Und ein normal tiefes Rack hätte da überhaupt nicht reingepasst.
Deswegen habe ich da jetzt meinen, ich glaube, 45 cm Mini-Rack.
Drinnen stehen 12 oder 15 Höheneinheiten.
Und deswegen habe ich auch ein Servergehäuse gebraucht, was kurz ist.
Und kurz bedeutet hoch, weil irgendwo muss das Netzteil und das Board herein.
Und Platten und alles.
War gar nicht so schwer, war gar nicht so einfach, da eins zu finden.
So ein passendes Gehäuse.
Ja, und das Ding hat halt aktuell alles drinne, was irgendwie so läuft.
Das Ding macht Firewall mit PFSense, macht Heimautomatisierung, macht, ich habe es vorhin gezeigt,
macht irgendwie jetzt mal über den Daumen gepeilt 15 verschiedene Sachen.
Und wenn das System nicht mehr geht, ist scheiße.
Dann geht halt hier im Haus einiges nicht.
Ja, von Internet bis Rollensteuerung automatisch bis.
Videos angucken bis, nicht mal Fernseh, es geht nichts im Endeffekt.
Das ist bis jetzt noch kein Problem gewesen, weil das Ding relativ gut aufgestellt ist, ja.
Ich meine, es hat kein doppeltes Netzteil drinne, aber das ist ein halbwegs gutes BeQuiet-Netzteil.
Mit absolut null Last richtig drauf, das geht nicht so einfach kaputt.
Ja, das hat einen ZFS-Rate, also sprich, selbst wenn eine Platte kaputt geht.
Und hier nochmal eine Rate 1 über die SSDs.
Und dann hast du einen ordentlichen SAS-Controller.
Also das Ding ist schon recht ausfallsicher, da muss man sich keine Gedanken machen eigentlich.
Aber es ist halt trotzdem ein bisschen Overkill.
Das kommt dann noch dazu.
So, und deswegen wird die Kiste jetzt abgelöst durch ein kleines Vierkern-Celeron-Board,
was wir hier gerade einrichten.
Einen 5-Port-Microtech-Router für Netzwerke und Internet-Kram.
Wenn da kommen immer noch Switche dran, dann ist das 5 Ports reichen Dicke aus.
5 Ports, internes Netzwerk, zum Provider und zum Access-Point im Endeffekt.
Ja, vielleicht noch eins für eine DMZ, mal gucken.
Also 5 Ports reichen Dicke, selbst in zwei Providern reichen 5 Ports Dicke.
Hat das Ding eine USV? Ja, eine USV hat es auch.
Und zwar, da, da, da ist die USV.
Da macht es halt Klappe.
Das da, das ist die USV.
Ja, das ist die USV.
Wenn man so eine USV schon mal go-mant, weiß man, dass auch kleine USVs sind.
Äh, schwer.
Da oben drüber ist noch ein billiger TP-Link-Switch, das Unity Media Modem, eine Steckdosenleiste.
Äh, hier sieht man den...
Hier sieht man den 10G-Switch.
Da, das ist, das ist einfach nur so ein, so ein...
Das ist auch nicht mal ein richtiges Patch-Panel, einfach so was, wo, wo Stecker reinklipsen kann.
Ja.
Genau, und äh, die Kiste, die behalte ich auch.
Die, äh, schalte ich halt aus und verwende sie nur noch zu Testzwecken.
Und dann habe ich das Ganze ein bisschen entschleunigt.
Klack!
Erstens brauchen die drei kleinen Sachen viel,
noch mal weniger Strom.
Der hier braucht schon nicht viel, ja.
Also das ganze Rack,
das ganze Rack braucht insgesamt idle um die hundert Watt.
Bisschen weniger sogar.
Man sieht es hier glaube ich am Anfang.
Hier.
Irgendwie 98 oder irgendwas steht da.
Ähm, also idle brauch es irgendwie so,
pff, sagen wir mal so 85, 90 Watt.
Das klingt jetzt,
vielleicht für jemanden, der sowas noch nicht hat,
was er nicht betrieben hat, klingt jetzt erstmal viel, dass du quasi irgendwie 9,24,7 Verbrauch hast,
aber man muss sagen, für ein Setup ist das nicht viel.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr sparsam für sowas.
Genau, Grosso Dango, das ist eigentlich, ist das nichts, das ist wirklich wenig.
Nichtsdestotrotz verbraucht es natürlich trotzdem.
Also auch wenn es eigentlich nicht viel ist, ist es trotzdem für Rumgeeidler eigentlich zu viel.
Ähm, man muss aber dazu sagen, es ist gar nicht mal so, dass der Server das jetzt alles verbraucht,
weil im Prinzip sind drei 10T-Platten drin.
Das heißt, wenn die nicht gerade sleepen, was sie zum größten Teil machen, wenn nicht gerade was passiert,
ähm, verbrauchen die auch schon mal ordentlich was.
Ähm, der 10G-Switch zieht auch mal was, weil der zieht halt einfach was, da kann ich nichts dagegen machen.
Ähm, so ein USV braucht natürlich auch nochmal ein bisschen was, wenn es durchgeht.
Also sagen wir mal so, der Server ist ungefähr für,
naja, sagen wir mal, zwei Drittel vom Stromverbrauch verantwortlich.
Der Rest ist halt, naja, ja, doch.
Na, da kommt noch Fritzbox, Unity Media, Kabelmodem, das braucht auch nochmal ein bisschen was.
Ähm, sagen wir mal so, der Server verbraucht 65% vom Strom.
Von dem ganzen, des ganzen Setup her.
Und da kann ich, da kann ich erstens ein bisschen was einsparen.
Und zweitens halt mein Setup.
Wieder so aufstellen, dass halt nicht eine Kiste alles macht.
Ähm, an die ich mich gar nicht mehr richtig traue, quasi ranzugehen.
Weil, selbst wenn ich sie einfach nur neu starte, nach einem Update,
äh, in der Zwischenzeit der Fernseher nicht geht.
Also das ist halt, es ist zwar technisch irgendwie ganz cool, ja.
Aber auf ein Kill.
Ja.
Das ist so ein Bloodpack.
Das ist, ich sag ja, 100%, es ist nichts eigentlich für ein ordentliches Setup.
Gar nichts, es ist nicht viel.
Äh, kenne mich da nicht so aus, aber wieso brauchst du das für Internet und sowas?
Einfach hobbymäßig, wo hat man irgendwelche Vorteile?
Naja, irgendwo muss man den Kram ja laufen lassen.
Irgendwo muss man seinen Kram ja laufen lassen.
Du hast, man hat die Möglichkeit, sagen wir mal, viel, viel Cloud-technisch zu machen,
wenn man das nicht, äh, self-hosted laufen lassen will.
Wenn du allerdings Sachen halt daheim laufen lassen möchtest und nicht in irgendeiner Cloud.
Irgendwo müssen die Dinger ja drauflaufen.
Kommt, irgendwo muss es ja laufen.
Irgendwo kommst du ja nicht drumherum.
Und, ähm, bei mir läuft es halt auf der Kiste.
Ja.
Gut, ähm, so, jetzt haben wir Home Assistant-Dings installiert.
Ja, was wir heute einrichten gerade, ist die Kiste, die quasi den Heimautomatisierungs- und Fernsehteil
von meiner 4HE-Super-Server-Single-Point-of-Failure-Kiste...
Warum Fernseh nicht läuft?
Weil da, weil Fernseh quasi...
Stell dir die, stell dir die Dose, stell dir die Dose vor von Unity Media, die da aus der Wand kommt.
Na, man sieht sie hier im Video sogar irgendwo.
Äh, da, hier, guck mal.
Da ist, da ist die Unity Media-Dose, dahinter, hier, da.
Da, ne, ich, ich, ich, ich zoome da jetzt nicht hin, aber, ja, da.
Da kommt Unity Media raus.
Mehrfach.
Kommt da Unity Media raus.
Dann geht Unity Media an eine TV-Karte.
Die TV-Karte.
Da muss ich mir erst mal, wie, wie komplex das Setup eigentlich ist, ja.
Also, ein Setup, was quasi von der Architektur her schön ist, muss nicht, muss nicht einfach sein und vor allem nicht einfach, äh, in der, in der Handhabung her.
Also, das Kabel geht raus in eine TV-Karte.
Die TV-Karte steckt in dieser 4HE-Kiste drinnen.
Die TV-Karte selbst ist in einem Container eingebunden, wo, den LXC-Container, wo TV-Head-End draufläuft.
TV-Head-End macht quasi, äh, Timeshift, Aufnahmen, Live-TV und sonst was, ja.
Und, äh, drüben im Wohnzimmer oder auch hier auf der Kiste, haben wir, äh, drüben im Wohnzimmer habe ich ein Nvidia Shield TV stehen.
Da läuft Kodi drauf und Kodi als Oberfläche halt auf dem Fernseher verbindet sich zu diesem TV-Head-End-Server, der dann quasi das Fernsehprogramm streamt.
Was halt ganz praktisch ist.
Weil, so hast du keine Probleme mit, ähm, welches Gerät was guckt, ne.
Es ist quasi ab dem TV-Head-End ist alles Netzwerk-Stream.
Also sprich, es könnten 15 Leute im Haus, die es nicht gibt, aber könnten, keine Ahnung, 15 Leute im Haus, bis das Netzwerk zusammenbricht, äh, den gleichen Fernsehsender gucken.
Das ist vollkommen egal.
Und das Ding macht halt auch Aufnahmen, weil es dann eh an ist, 24-7.
Und deswegen geht Fernsehen nicht.
Weil Fernseher auch da drüber geht.
Ja, der Rollladen geht, der, also der Rollladen geht noch.
Also der Rollladen mit Kurbel geht natürlich eh.
Weil, ganz logisch, der hat einen Kurbel, äh, mit, mit, äh, Gurt.
Der geht natürlich eh, weil, den Gurt kann ich noch nicht fernsteuern.
Äh, aber die Rollläden, die automatisch funktionieren, die gehen auch noch mit dem Knopf, der da ist, aber was nicht mehr funktioniert ist, dass die Rollläden automatisch, äh, morgens hoch und abends runter gehen.
Weil ich das über Home Assistant gelöst habe und Home Assistant läuft, wer hätte das gedacht?
Auf dem System mit.
Smart Home Basisstation, ja, genau, genau.
Äh, Home Assistant ist, äh, nen, ne Heimatomatisierungssoftware, die quasi, ähm, ganz viele verschiedene Hersteller miteinander verbinden kann.
So, dass man nicht auf einen Hersteller festgelegt ist.
Welche Linux-Distribute nutzt du hier?
Du meinst jetzt auf dem System?
Oder, oder die 4M, die ich hier hab?
Also meinst du das, was wir hier auf dem Server laufen haben, oder, oder Desktop?
4M, das ist Manjaro mit i3.
Manjaro.
Manjaro mit i3, mit, äh, Gnome Terminal und einem T-Max drin und ein bisschen halt Custom-Farben und Gedulds angepasst, ne.
So, jetzt haben wir Home Assistant, äh, install, ähm, install, jup.
Ja, Gozo, man kann immer noch, man kann's immer noch, noch mehr übertreiben.
Oh, was ich jetzt, was ich letztens gesehen hab, sehr nice, ähm.
Was ich bei uns in, entweder in Flur und in Hof oder nur in Hof und nur in Flur, ähm, einbauen will, hab ich letztens in einem Video gesehen.
Muss ich grad mal kurz raussuchen in der History auf dem zweiten, auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Und zwar LED-Beleuchtung für außen.
Und zwar eine ordentlich helle LED.
Ordentlich helle LED-Beleuchtung für draußen.
Äh, ja, hier in dem Video hat er tut das gezeigt, ähm.
Das da.
Genau.
Ja, quasi, sowas wie LED, na, Strahler, weiß ich nicht.
So Deckenbeleuchtung halt, so, ne, oder, oder Terrassenbeleuchtung oder halt so, so Dinger, die man quasi in so, wenn man, wenn man da schon so eine Einbuchtung hat, die man so reinmachen kann.
Ähm.
Steht hier irgendwie, wie, wie hell das ist?
Ne, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ganz nice.
Kannst du nämlich auch mit Home Assistant steuern.
Und die Dinger sind halt schön hell und man, man kann die Farben anpassen, so wie es gerade nett ist, ne.
Da zeigt es am Ende auch ein bisschen, wie er das in seinem Haus gemacht hat.
Gut, das ist, das ist seine, seine, ja hier da, sieht man die Dinger.
Das, das sind die Teile.
Und die sind schon ordentlich hell, das ist schon ganz nice, ja.
Der Typ hat es eh komplett übertrieben mit seinem Haus, ne.
Wer sich für Heimatomatisierung interessiert, kann sich die Videos von dem angucken, die sind schon ganz cool.
Aber der hat es halt voll übertrieben mit seinem Haus, der Dude, ne.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt euch das mal an, ey.
Der hat es halt voll massiv übertrieben.
Sogar die, die Zuckerstangen gehen, gehen LED beleuchtet an und aus.
Der ist halt massiv übertrieben, der Typ.
Wenn der da drin CSGO spielt, ist alles, alles Instant Header, ey.
Bei so viel RGB-Beleuchtung.
Und wenn er dann noch den Gaming-Handschuh anhat, den wir uns letztens angeschaut haben, dann ist es vorbei.
Alter, guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist halt übelst nice.
Ich habe letztens schon mal ein Video gezeigt, aber weil ich es so geil finde, zeige ich es nochmal allen, die es nicht gesehen haben von ihm.
Der hat auch ein Video, also könnt ihr mal gucken bei ihm hier, das ist TheHookUp auf YouTube, der macht relativ viele Heimatomatisierungsvideos.
Der hat ein Video gezeigt von seiner kompletten Hausbeleuchtung, die er über Home Assistant steuert.
Hier siehst du, hier kannst du auch die LEDs und so einstellen.
Ja, das ist die Oberfläche, die ich auch verwende, halt nicht mit so viel RGB-Beleuchtung.
Und der hat es halt echt, wenn man sich das hier anguckt,
der hat es halt komplett übertrieben mit RGB-Beleuchtung, ne?
Und der hat ein anderes Video, wo er zeigt, was er für Netzteile hat.
Der hat sich irgendwie erstmal, hat sich irgendwie erstmal, ich bin mir nicht mehr genau sicher, welches war,
der hat sich irgendwie erstmal 3200 Watt Server-Netzteile oder so geholt, dass er,
oder nicht Server-Netzteile, 3200 Watt Netzteile geholt, dass das überhaupt zuverlässig alles läuft, RGB-Beleuchtung.
Bäm.
Aber man muss sagen, geil ist es schon, ne?
Vor allem, wenn die bisschen abgedrehteren Sachen dann am Ende kommen und so.
Weil nice ist es schon.
Das ist, das ist schon nice, ja?
Ja, du kannst das ja programmieren, wie du willst.
Der hat, der hat auch richtig coole Sachen.
Äh, der hat, der hat so ein Halloween-Ding.
Das habe ich das letzte Mal schon nicht gefunden.
Da erscheinen so, erscheinen die LEDs so wie Augen im Dunkeln und so, auch übelst geil.
Das ist schon cool.
Also ich finde das echt sehr nice, was der da gebaut hat.
Äh, Stromrechnung will man sich damit wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wirklich angucken.
Der Kerl, der verbraucht wahrscheinlich um Weihnachten und, und Halloween bei denen, äh, so viel rum wie das restliche Jahr immer.
Guck mal, das ist doch geil, oder?
Wie so die Augen aufploppen und wieder einfaden und so.
Das ist doch cool.
Das ist voll kreativ, die Idee auch da drauf zu kommen, ne?
LED-S brauchen nicht so viel, allerdings, was weiß ich, 15.000 LED-S oder wie viel auch immer der da hat, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Die brauchen halt schon wieder ein bisschen was, ne?
Der zeigt es irgendwo in dem Video.
Auch, was er sich hier gekauft hat an, äh, an Netzteilen.
Ja.
Haha.
Ne.
Okay, ich, ich, ich finde es nicht mehr, aber der hat, äh,
der hat irgendwo die Netzteile gezeigt, die er hat.
Und das sind echt fette, fette Dinger.
Ja, es zieht auch schon ein bisschen was.
Hier, da hat er das Netzteil.
Ach Gott, doch keine Tausendteile.
2200, hab ich Mist erzählt.
Da hat er irgendwie ein paar Stück am Start.
Also, das, das frisst schon ordentlich.
Und das braucht ein bisschen was.
So, install, bla bla bla.
So, und jetzt starten wir das mal.
Gucken, ob's läuft.
Und dann gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, wann's läuft.
Ne, energieeffizient sind die Dinger wirklich nicht.
Ich hab letztens auch ein paar LEDs gegrillt, aus Versehen.
Ich hab mit so nem, mit so nem Steck, Steckboard und nem Raspberry
ein bisschen rumgebastelt, hab den falschen Widerstand reingemacht.
Und dann, äh, haben die LEDs auf einmal nichts mehr gemacht.
Und das Kabel danach ist das Plastik weggeschmolzen.
Und dann hab ich jetzt alle, was stinkt denn hier so,
hab ich dann festgestellt, das war der falsche Widerstand.
Und hab ein bisschen was kaputt gemacht.
Aber das war ja nur so klein Bastelzeug, ist nicht viel kaputt gegangen.
Also, das kostet ja nicht, ist nicht die Welt jetzt.
So ein Set.
So ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Teileset mit Kabel und so, kostet 20 Euro oder so.
Wo man, da sind halt viel mehr drin, als die, die ich kaputt gemacht hab, ne.
Also, kompletten Satz an LEDs und Steckboards und Widerstände und Kabels und so, ist da massig drin.
Das ist ja noch genug übrig.
Kann man ab und zu mal ein bisschen was kaputt machen.
So, ist das jetzt gestartet mittlerweile mal?
Ja.
Da läuft's.
Ich darf wieder nicht reinklicken?
Ja, sag mal.
Jetzt geht's.
Ich lass mal in Exklusiv-Mode aus, mal gucken, was da ist.
Bis denn, goso, dango.
Ich muss mal gucken, es gibt bei mir auch demnächst Weihnachtsfutter-Stells noch.
Ich muss mal kurz nachgucken, wann's das gibt.
Wartet mal, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wieder am Start, also bis 18 Uhr hab ich noch Zeit.
Gut, ähm, dann schauen wir doch mal, ob das Home Assistant-Zeug läuft.
Ja, wunderbar.
Passwort, Admin, Passwort 123456.
Ach nee, Admin.
Super, Special Passwort.
Das werde ich eher nachher noch alles ändern.
Also nie.
Ihr kennt mich ja.
Was genau soll das sein?
Hat der irgendwie mein Shield-TV discovered oder sowas?
Kann das sein?
Android.local.
Ja, das wird mein Shield-TV sein, denke ich mal.
Was er da discovered hat.
Was der alles macht.
Yes.
Okay, äh, Home Assistant funktioniert.
Das ist schon mal schön.
Passwort liegt, ja.
Ganz furchtbar.
Komplexes, äh, hoch, äh, wahnsinnig secures Passwort.
So, bla bla bla.
Ja, bist du jetzt.
Configure Auto Start.
Ja, das wollen wir machen.
Was, was ist denn eigentlich für eine Home Assistant-Version dabei?
Okay.
Falls überhaupt.
Ob da überhaupt einer dabei ist.
Nee, die bringen, liefern gar keine mit.
Was ja auch sinnvoll ist, ne.
Braucht, braucht kein Mensch mitgeliefert.
Und die mitgelieferte Variante wird eh keiner verwenden.
Äh.
Wobei ich das eigentlich gar nicht als Root laufen lassen will.
Fällt mir da gerade auf.
Vielleicht installieren wir das nochmal.
Und zwar als nicht.
Weil im Heimatverzeichnis vom Root ist schon irgendwie, äh, beknackt, ne.
Da war ein extra User für.
Kennst du eigentlich die Turnkey-Elektrie?
Ja, kennst du eigentlich die Turnkey-Elektrie?
Wie deaktiviert man denn an Python?
Python HA, äh, Dings, äh.
Habt ihr's nie richtig verwendet?
Deactivate!
Easy.
Oh, die Musik ist aus.
Ist die Musik aus?
Das geht immer.
Zeller-Musik ist das Beste.
Dildid, didildid, didildid.
Okay, ähm.
Okay, Home Assistant haben wir jetzt installiert.
Und wir deinstallieren jetzt gleich wieder.
Jetzt hat's voll geblieben.
Das hat's voll gebracht.
Das hat's voll gebracht, äh.
Äh, und jetzt
fügen wir einen neuen User hinzu.
Und zwar einen
HA-User.
Unix-Passwort, also 3456.
Yes, natürlich ist die Information korrekt.
So, und jetzt
Quizfrage.
Es gibt einen 0,1 Cent
G2A-Gutschein zu gewinnen.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen
SU-User,
also SU-HA,
oder SU-HA?
Quizfrage.
Ähm, Ice-Kolter, das wird
ein Teil meiner Ablösung
für meinen super fetten 4-HE
Single Point of Failure
Super-Server.
Er wird hier aufgesplittet
in eine kleine Vierkern-Celeron-Kiste,
einen Mikrotik-Router
und einen Mini-NAS.
Ja, das ist, äh,
im Prinzip schon so
alles, was ich hier habe.
Alles ist nicht so falsch, was ihr schreibt.
Das stimmt auch alles,
aber das ist nicht der Unterschied.
Was macht denn das Minus?
Also ich, ich werde es euch jetzt einfach erzählen.
Ähm,
das Minus führt die Logging-Skripte aus.
Und das ohne Minus nicht.
Deswegen
habe ich auch, wenn ich mich mit Minus einlogge,
ähm, und, und Environment gucke,
nämlich das, was da Steiner, äh, äh,
Steinerix gerade geschrieben hat, ist dann auch so,
dann sind die ganzen Environments gesetzt,
wie wenn ich dieser User wäre.
Ähm, und ohne Minus, äh,
will so ein bisschen was übrig von, von meinem anderen User.
Also im Prinzip ist zu Minus in der Regel das, was man will.
Alternativ gibt es dann auch so was wie
sudo –u, ähm,
ha –i
und so was in der Richtung macht, glaube ich,
genau das Gleiche.
Minus –i ist Interactive Login.
Und ohne Minus –i muss ein Programm ausgeben,
was es macht.
Und dann, äh, nicht.
Aber ich, kurz und klar, ja, so.
So.
Scheiße!
Haha, Sebaru.
Ne, Berufsschule ist der größte Crap überhaupt.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Also erstens,
würden mir nach dem ersten Tag schon mal alle Schüler massiv auf den Sack gehen.
Dann zu würden mir wahrscheinlich alle meine Kollegen auf den Sack gehen.
Und das komplette System und die IHK auf den Sack gehen.
Also, warum sollte ich jemals Berufsschule erwerben?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Berufsschule ist sinnlos.
Sinnlos ist es überhaupt.
Was meint ihr?
Irgendjemand, der absolut keine Ahnung hat von dem Beruf und sich hinsetzt, also mal angenommen,
ihr nehmt jetzt, keine Ahnung, nehmt mal den Friseur zum Beispiel, ja, nehmt mal den Fabian
als Beispiel.
Und dann nehmt mal den, sagen wir mal den Sebaru, ja, wenn wir jetzt die zwei nehmen
würden.
Und, äh, der Sebaru geht arbeiten, geht in die Berufsschule, und, äh, der Sebaru geht
arbeiten, geht in die Berufsschule.
Und, äh, der Sebaru geht arbeiten, geht in die Berufsschule, und, äh, der Sebaru geht arbeiten, geht in die Berufsschule.
Und der Fabian wird sich hinsetzen und quasi ein halbes Jahr lang IHK-Prüfungen lernen, also
quasi so ein halbes Jahr, bevor das Sebaru Abschlussarbeit schreiben müsste, wird sich
der Fabian hinsetzen und Abschlussprüfungen lernen.
Also sprich, du hast einen, der sich auskennt, und du hast einen anderen, der eigentlich
keine Ahnung hat, aber dreist ein halbes Jahr lang IHK-Abschlussprüfungen geübt hat.
Was meint ihr, wer wird die bessere Prüfung schreiben?
Oder sagen wir mal so, packen wir uns beide, ja?
Packen wir uns beide?
Ähm, und ich gehe davon aus, dass der Fabian die bessere Prüfung hätte, weil die IHK-Prüfungen
komplett für den Arsch sind.
Wir können uns mal irgendwann, das machen wir, wir gucken uns wirklich mal, da muss
mir aber einer von euch den Link schicken, weil nicht, dass mir irgendeiner vorwerfen
kann, ich hätte da irgendwas gepirated oder so, ähm, ein paar IHK-Prüfungen im Stream
angucken.
Das machen wir.
Das schreibe ich mir auf.
Äh, ja, und Berufsschule bringt an sich gar nichts.
Also, ich, ich finde, Berufsschule ist so.
Sinnlos gewesen.
Ich meine, ich fand's gut.
Weil man, weil man sich komplett, äh, das war, das war im Prinzip wie Urlaub, Berufsschule,
ja?
Berufsschule war echt wie Urlaub.
Ich habe einfach nur da gesessen und, ja, Löcher in die Luft geguckt im Endeffekt.
Und du musst nach der Berufsschule auch nicht mehr auf die Arbeit, was natürlich noch viel
geiler ist.
Habe vor einiger Zeit die IHK-Abschlussprüfung gemacht, fand die Fragen absolut dumm und
zum Teil mehrdeutig.
Ja, sind sie auch.
Soll ich sie, ja, macht man sie, Bauer.
Ja.
Wenn wir die, wenn wir die dann im Stream zeigen dürfen?
Dann gucken wir uns die Barus, die Barus-Abschlussarbeit an, oder die Barus, äh, Zwischenprüfung
oder so.
Dann sehen wir mal, wie dumm die IHK-Prüfungen sind, äh.
Richtig dumm, ja.
An den Verein muss ich jetzt auch einmal im Jahr 50 Euro Gebühren bezahlen, ne?
Einfach so muss jeder, muss jeder, jeder, der eine Firma gründet, ähm, oder der,
der, äh, halt den Antrag ausfüllt.
Wenn ich zu klein gelitten muss, die IHK-Gebühren bezahlen.
Bam.
Ich meine, 50 Euro im Jahr sind nicht viel.
Aber ich weiß dann überhaupt nicht, wofür ich das eigentlich bezahlen soll.
Ich habe mit denen noch nie was zu tun.
Und ich, also, in meiner Ausbildung arbeite ich mit der Firma nicht.
Und, ähm, außer, dass die mir abends so Briefe schicken und so eine komische IHK-Rundschau
oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung, wofür ich die 50 Euro bezahle.
100 Euro, boah.
Nice, die Barus.
Okay, ähm, Home Assistant funktioniert.
Auch als eigener User, so muss das sein.
So, was brauchen wir denn als nächstes?
Einen Summer brauchen wir nicht.
Summer brauchen wir auf der Kiste garantiert nicht.
Ähm, das ist wie der Rundfunkbeitrag, so ungefähr.
Home Assistant Engine X haben wir drauf.
Ein TV-Head ein brauchen wir noch.
Für Fernsehkram.
Mal gucken, welche Version dabei ist.
Wie die liefern.
Wie, die liefern gar keins mehr mit?
Lull.
Na gut.
Dann installieren wir es halt aus denen ihren Repos.
Sonst hätte ich halt das Offizielle genommen, weil, warum nicht, ne.
Offizielle Pakete sind in der Regel immer besser, was Updates und so anbelangt.
Aber, naja.
Dann, installieren wir es halt aus denen ihren Repos.
So, was brauch ich denn noch?
Ich brauch mein...
Ich brauch mein Home Assistant drauf.
Ich muss jetzt noch mal auf Home Assistant drauf.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal auf meinen anderen Server gucken,
weil ich da aktuell drauflaufen hab.
Äh, 1.60.
Müssen wir gucken, was da für Docker-Gestells läuft.
Nicht H-Top.
Äh, Docker-Gedöns läuft da drauf.
Da läuft, was hab ich denn da für Docker-Geschiss drauflaufen?
Organizer?
Ja, das braucht man nicht unbedingt.
Äh, und der Rest ist Home Assistant-Gedöns.
So, und auf meinem...
Auf der anderen Kiste?
Auf der anderen Kiste läuft...
Achso, erstmal root werden.
Ja, ist gut.
So, Nextcloud...
Na, Nextcloud lass ich nicht.
Nextcloud läuft im Internet,
sondern nicht auf der Kiste, wo wir jetzt drauf sind.
Ähm...
Samba und Gedöns kommt auf das NAS.
Das kommt da auch nicht drauf.
Das P-Hole könnten wir noch drauf machen.
Das wollte ich wieder ausprobieren.
Das P-Hole wollte ich mal jetzt ausprobieren wieder.
Das P-Hole...
Das hört sich echt pervers an, oder?
Den P-Hole wollte ich mal wieder ausprobieren.
Ähm...
Weil letztens hatten wir es ja im Stream von,
dass es angeblich nicht mal das Problem gibt,
dass die Browser dadurch hängen bleiben.
Das probieren wir doch mal aus.
Das installieren wir uns doch jetzt dazu.
Nextcloud kommt intern.
Mail-Backup kommt auch intern.
Fritzbox, äh...
Fritzbox-Kontakte-Sync kommt noch drauf und TV-Headern.
Gut.
Brauchen wir jetzt...
Müssen wir einen P-Hole installieren und einen TV-Headern noch.
Und dann haben wir zum größten Teil alles.
Siehste?
Und das meine ich ja im Prinzip.
Ist das Setup ja relativ simpel.
Da brauchen wir kein LXC und kein Docker und kein sonst was.
Einfach die drei Dienste auf das System geknallt und gut ist.
Gerade erst dazu gekommen.
Was geht's heute?
Ähm...
Ich hab doch meinen 4HE-Super...
Äh...
Superserver, der alles macht bei mir im Haus noch rumstehen.
Und ich will den jetzt ablösen durch drei kleinere Sachen.
Nämlich einen MikroTik-Router,
ein stromsparendes 4-Kern-Celeron-Board und ein Mini-NAS.
Braucht weniger Strom und ist nicht mehr so anfällig.
Und das ist ein Teil davon.
Das ist hier die Celeron-Kiste.
Mit 4 Kern.
Für Heimautomatisierung und sonst was.
So.
Ich bin vergesslich.
Also, was?
Genau.
TV-Headern müssen wir installieren.
Und einen P-Hole.
Ubuntu.
Was viel toller ist.
Ähm...
In YouTube-Videos.
Wenn da irgendwie einer Ubuntu installiert,
dann sagt der nicht Ubuntu,
sondern die coolen Leute sagen immer
Ubantu.
Und wenn man sich überlegt,
das kommt ja irgendwie aus Südafrika oder so,
man spricht es unter Garantie.
Ich kann keinen Südafrika...
Was spreche ich?
Südafrika-Französisch?
Keine Ahnung.
Äh...
Es ist...
Bin ich mir so sicher,
dass es dort auf jeden Fall Ubuntu heißt
und nicht Ubuntu.
Garantiert nicht.
Install.
Install für...
Für...
Ubantu hätte ich das gerne.
Ja?
Wie?
Ist das die einzige Install-Variante?
Irgendwelche komischen Installer nach Bash zu pipen oder was?
Na, ich weiß ja nicht.
Hat der keine Repo oder so?
Ich will mir das Install-Skript da eigentlich gar nicht durchlesen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich will einfach eine Repo haben.
Ah, wir haben keine Repo.
Na?
Oder?
Oh, Bones.
Ja, das klingt auch viel Afrikanischer.
Jaja, die wollen eigentlich die Installer anzeigen.
Ja, die machen das wirklich alle über diesen komischen... über diesen komischen Installer-Skript.
Hä?
Ich bin kein Fan von irgendwelchen Installer-Skript nach Bash Pipen als root.
Das ist eigentlich so... nicht so da way.
Da way ist das.
Ja, wobei, das ist out, das ist ja mittlerweile auch eine andere Sache.
Auch ein Docker-Container.
Wir haben uns ja explizit dafür entwickelt.
entschieden nicht zu Docker-Containern auf der Kiste. 20? Was machst du mit 20
Raspberries? Also ich komme aktuell nur auf meinen Keller den, den anderen, den
den, den für Gegensprech-Dings stellst und den haben eigentlich, ich komme auf drei
Raspberry Zeros und einen Raspberry 3, der aber eigentlich nur noch läuft und nichts
macht, die, die im Betrieb sind. Ich habe zwar hier auch noch ein paar rumliegen,
aber 20? 20 ist hart. Was machst du mit den 20? Okay, wir copy-pasten einfach die
Repos von denen und gut ist. Sudo brauchen wir also gut, garantiert nicht. Okay,
apt-update und dann gucken wir, ob es ein TV hier dann gibt. Also wenn du nicht
weißt, was du mit einem Raspberry Pi machen sollst, es gibt so ein paar Dinge,
wie gesagt, von denen ich denke, das ist nicht schlecht. Falls Pi-Hole mittlerweile
was taugt, dann taugt es das auch zu einer Sache. Das erste ist, sich mal mit
Linux auseinanderzusetzen. Dafür ist es wirklich praktisch. Vor allem halt mal
mit einem Linux, was nicht in der VM ist, weil man da schon potenziell ein paar
andere Probleme haben kann, so nach dem Motto, was macht man, wenn das Ding jetzt im
Reboot hängt oder so, was du bei der VM nicht hast. Die schatzt du einfach neu und siehst halt trotzdem.
Ähm,
und das nächste sind irgendwelche Heimautomatisierungsgeschichten. Achso,
ja, Heimautomatisierungsansätze sind auch praktisch. Und das nächste ist es,
mit irgendwelchen Addons zu versehen. Zum Beispiel einem Automation Head,
wo du dann irgendwelche Geräte messen kannst oder über die GPIO-Pins schalten kannst.
Luftfeuchtigkeitsmesser, Temperaturmesser, aber gut, das ist eher was im Rahmen,
wenn man sich verhalten möchte. Aber das ist eher was im Rahmen, wenn man sich verhalten möchte.
Ich broke jetzt meine absoluten Kanäle. Ich hab jetzt direktingen mit meiner dem
Heimautomatisierung insgesamt installiert und die Musik ist übelst leise auf einmal.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten, ich mein, wenn man da jetzt nicht den konkreten Anwendungsfall hat oder
so, dann ist der er einfach nur für irgendwas, was so pauschal sinnvoll ist, weiß ich nicht.
Da gibt's eigentlich nichts.
Oh, jetzt ist es auf einmal wieder laut. Jetzt
wieder nicht.
Nintendo weiß nicht, was sie wollen. Da untonerleise.
Die haben sie eingeschaltet.
Ja.
Umf portsufnertelich, ne, Ah!
Also, sah Zelda in Breath of the Wild so aus? Nee, oder?
Das ist eher, das ist eher so die, die, keine Ahnung, das ist die, keine Ahnung, was, welche Zelda-Reinkarnation das sein soll.
Das ist die Weep-Zelda.
Ja, Telekom kommt bei mir auch weg.
Sobald ich Unity Media umgestellt hab und mein IPv4 noch ordentlich funktioniert, wie sie es versprochen haben,
kommt die Telekom, sobald ich kündigen kann, weg.
Also ich glaube, ich kann im Juni oder so, kann ich Telekom kündigen.
Bam.
Weg.
Weggeklatscht.
Telekom.
Das Einzige, was ich noch machen muss, ist die Rufnummer portieren.
Die portiere ich zu so einem, äh, 2,50 Euro, äh, VoIP-Provider und dann ist gut.
Okay, wir wollten jetzt noch P-Holes, nee, nee, TV-Header.
Moment.
Ist das jetzt blöd?
Ach, Moment, ich hab ja nur den Key geändert, ich hab ja das Repo noch gar nicht geändert.
Wo steht denn das Repo hier?
Ähm, hier.
Stable, Unstable, nee, nee, nee.
Ach, was machen die denn da?
Das da brauchen wir doch, den Rest brauchen wir nicht.
Was machen die denn da?
Sudo-
Ach so, die führen das einfach aus.
Das da brauchen wir nur, das ist alles.
Was für eine TV-Karte benutzt du eigentlich?
Das ist eine, ich sag's dir.
Ich muss nochmal kurz rumfahren mit dem Stuhl.
Das ist eine, äh, Wind-TV.
Quad-HD von Hauptauge, die gar nicht Hauptauge heißen, sondern irgendwie Hapasch oder so.
Die hatten ja mal eine Zeit lang, bevor Elgato auf die Idee kam, einfach deutlich bessere Hardware zu produzieren,
waren die mal relativ im Trend für Konsolen-Capture-Karten.
Und die haben dann irgendwie den Anschluss verpasst.
Jetzt kann man's installieren.
Fernsehen gibt's noch.
Oh ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich, wie gesagt, ich gucke kaum Fernsehen.
Chose the username for TV-Head-End-Administrator.
Admin.
Administrator-Passwort, haha.
Unser bestes Lieblingspasswort.
Warum ist die Zelda-Musik auf einmal so Jazz-Style-mäßig?
Da gefällt mir die klassische Sache vom 20-jährigen Jubiläum aber besser.
Was ist denn TV-Head-End?
Das ist ein TV-Server.
Damit kannst du Fernsehen aufnehmen.
Fernseh-Stream.
Nicht nur Fernsehen.
Also nicht nur Kabel.
Kannst damit alles.
PTV, Satellit, Unity Media.
Ja.
Und dann im Haus verteilen per Netzwerk.
Path of Exile, geiles Game.
Übelst geiles Game.
Da hab ich viele Stunden mit dem Fabian gespielt.
Schon als es neu war noch.
Als es Beta war noch.
Aber übelst geil.
Path of Exile ist auch der Grund, warum alle anderen Action-Hag-and-Slay-Dinger
nicht so gut sind.
Also, das ist auch der Grund, warum alle anderen Action-Hag-and-Slay-Dinger
Das sind einfach die guten Diablo-Leute von Blizzard.
Die haben sich gedacht, scheiß drauf, wir machen Path of Exile.
Okay, wir sind jetzt mal mutig.
Wir pipen jetzt einfach...
Das nach uns nach Bash.
Easy.
Das ist also genauso, wie man es nicht macht.
Okay, hier läuft auch...
Command Bash not found.
natürlich was denn sonst jetzt geht's ich will schon mal interessant dass ich
erstmal ein raspberry logo kriege das schafft vertrauen in das package was ist
denn das für ein geiles terminal das das ist kaum terminal und so ganz normales
glaubte ich will mein device nicht transformen ich will ich will einfach es
darauf installieren gehen wir weg abbrechen kann man das
abbrechen irgendwie ich will jetzt einfach zusätzlich installieren zu allem
anderen auch oder ist das ist das oder darf man das nicht sollte klappen wir
werden es ja sehen wenn ich muss ich noch mal neu installieren aber man okay
wenn man okay escape drückt dann ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man das weiß ich ob
ich das einfach darauf installieren sollte
japanischer gesagt ja oder zocker tim was willst du noch wissen also wie gesagt
das kann ich kann ja auch wenn du was willst ich habe schiss dass das mein
system irgendwie da was ist das problem zu transformt in ein p hole was ich so
gar nicht haben will vielleicht muss ich doch einen p-hole lxc container oder so
was hat draufhauen auch wenn ich das nicht so scharf drauf bin ehrlich gesagt was
klappt jetzt
mal wenn du das sagst das ist nicht überreicht wäre er falsch die maut so
innig fertig blieb bleibt man bei dhcp du kriegst schon der feste lease macht
ihr mal keine gedanken selekt upstream dns provider wo ist der cloud flair da
glaube cloud flair oder google touts ja ja 11 11 ist cloud flair
Cloudflare ist ja der neue Shit.
Select any list.
Alles.
Bam.
Protogons.
Ja, kann ich leider zur Zeit nicht mit.
Gibt es bei mir noch nicht.
Wobei, ich kann es ja mal einschalten.
Schadet ja nichts, ne?
Do you want to use...
No!
Ich will...
Ich will die HCP behalten.
Meine, die anderen unten rechts und den Sensor...
Ach so, das ist...
T-Max.
T-Max und einfach ein paar Splits mit...
Also hier unten läuft...
Watch-Sensors.
Und hier neben läuft ein Hardtop.
Und das ist T-Max.
Dieses...
Ding, mit dem ich die Fenster gesplittet habe.
Ich werde das Gefühl nicht los, dass ich P-Hole nicht installieren sollte,
wenn ich will, dass mein Server normal bleibt.
Probieren wir es mal.
Ich kann den mal noch neu installieren.
Overwatch-Altertiv-Spiel-Parladienst.
Weil der Hi-Rez so viel geiler ist, ne?
Das ist die Dekoronen-Song, ja.
Ne, ne, ne.
Ich installiere hier keinen P-Hole drauf.
Oh, meint ihr, das hat die IP schon gesetzt, oder was?
Weil, ähm...
Das ist mir zu...
Inversiv.
Ich glaube, ich mache da doch einen LXC-Container drauf
und lasse da P-Hole drauflaufen.
Alter, was ist mit der Musik los?
Was geht mit denen ab?
Soll es die Goronen-Musik sein?
Das hört...
Schon ein bisschen beknackt an.
Uh, uh, uh, uh.
Komm, scheiß drauf, YOLO.
Wir installieren jetzt einen P-Hole drauf und gucken, was passiert.
Für so was, für solche Testdinger,
dafür ist ein LXC-Container wirklich sehr praktisch.
Dafür ist ein LXC-Container praktisch.
Aber egal, muss ich den Server nochmal neu installieren,
wenn ich Pech habe.
Bam.
Also diese Zelda-30-Jahre-Compilation
ist mir viel zu Jazz-Style-mäßig.
Die gefällt mir nicht.
Nein, ich will kein Light-Hard-DPD,
weil ich Nginx schon installiert habe.
Locken Queries, nee, wozu?
Ah ja, warum nicht?
Warum eigentlich?
Warum soll ich DNS-Queries locken?
Wahrscheinlich für Statistiken von dem Ding.
Was soll schon schief gehen?
Macht das Ding nicht nur DNS-Queries?
Keine Ahnung, was das dreht alles.
Es wollte schon mal irgendwelche Web-Server installieren.
FTL.
Was zum Teufel ist FTL?
Ah, das ist FTL.
Das ist irgendeine API-Abfrage für DNS-Zeug.
Alter, das sieht wahr aus.
Monkatos.
Ah ja, da steht es.
FTL ist...
Warum taucht das hier, wo es erklärt wird,
nicht in der Seite auf?
Geil, oder?
Was suchst du danach?
Fass in den Leit-Domänen.
Ah, das ist irgendeine DNS-Mask.
Fork, oder was?
Ich glaube, das ist doch besser,
wenn ich sowas in einem Container laufen lasse.
Egal, wenn es hier ist, ist es einfach.
Ich meine, ich kann es immer noch installieren.
Äh, immer noch.
Zehn Minuten muss ich oft was fordern.
Okay, jetzt installen sie FTL.
Ich habe immer noch nicht genau verstanden,
was es macht, aber...
Du kannst sie nicht selbst sperren.
Das ist ja auch sinnvoll,
weil du kannst sie auch selbst dann nicht mehr entsperren.
Also ich muss sagen,
das Celeron-Zeug bleibt schön kühl.
Okay, dann gehen wir da mal drauf jetzt.
Verbinden.
Jawohl.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich mir mal merken.
Mein Admin-Passwort.
Ein nice Passwort, ja.
www.
Piotr, das sollte...
Ach so, ja, dann ist es doch easy.
Dann stimmt das gar nicht.
Da muss ich nicht admin, da muss ich dahin.
Das ist jetzt...
Jetzt kackt es ab.
Jetzt geht es nicht, weil...
Weil...
...den komischen Web-Server nicht mehr installiert wurde.
Ah, hier, n nginx-config.
Gif.
Da, blablabla, okay, das, das muss...
Warum um alles in der Welt brauche ich Apache-Utils,
wenn ich Nginx installiere?
Ha?
Warum?
Nein, ich will es gar nicht zu Defaults.
Jetzt geht die Musik wieder ab.
Oh.
Gucken wir mal, ob das irgendwie...
Server 18.
So vollkommener Blödsinn.
Ich will da noch mehr drauflaufen lassen.
Okay, das muss ich mir später mal in Ruhe angucken.
Ähm, das sieht sich nicht so aus,
als verträgt sich das mit, äh...
Hättest du mal lieber als Container gemacht.
Ja.
Stimmt.
Moin, schreibt die kalte Pizza.
Ich habe vor, mir auch einen Server einzurichten.
Als Fileserver, Gitserver und eventuell später noch
in DNS und Firewall.
Ich bin allerdings wirklich nur auf dem guten Moment an.
Fehlt mir so ein bisschen die Idee,
was ich brauche.
Was, was genau?
Was du...
Du meinst Hardware?
Oder...
Was du...
Dann...
Für Settings und, und so brauchst.
So, ich starte den Server jetzt mal neu.
Und gucke mal.
Und gucke mal, ob das mit dem...
Mit dem Unlocken über SSH noch funktioniert.
Warum hat der rebooted?
Warum hat der einfach rebooted?
Der darf nicht einfach rebooten.
Ich habe vorhin extra was installiert,
was, was ihn davon abhält, einfach zu rebooten.
Was sagt meine Elgato?
Der...
Warum reboote der einfach?
Das war doch garantiert der P-Hole-Installer,
der dann wieder mein Zeug deinstalliert hat.
Kack den, fliegt wieder weg.
Fliegt wieder runter.
Mach ich nachher nochmal neu.
Und schmeißt es weg.
Wahrscheinlich geht auch das Unlocken jetzt nicht.
Wartet es mal ab.
Ja, nice.
Der P-Hole hat es komplett kaputt gemacht.
Von wegen, irgendjemand, der geschrieben hat,
es geht zu easy.
Es geht nicht.
Es geht nicht easy.
Kann Elgato mal sich wieder,
Ding, mal wieder gehen jetzt?
Geht es jetzt wieder, Elgato?
Stell es, ja.
Jetzt ist meine IP auf einmal 168.
Aber alles gut.
Was war denn Tempel-OS-Nummer?
Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Da habe ich letztens irgendwas drüber gelesen.
Was war denn das?
Das ist nicht das Kirchen-Linux gewesen, oder?
Doch, das war das doch.
Aber das war nicht das Kirchen-Linux,
das war das, ja,
das ist das Nicht-Kirchen-Linux, das, äh.
Du musst essen gehen, stimmt.
Muss ich.
Mache ich auch jetzt.
Okay, jetzt habe ich,
ah, ne.
Da habe ich jetzt die IP für behalten,
was auch immer.
Scheint irgendwie übel zu random.
Ach, ne, das hat ja eine feste IP gesetzt.
Ich muss mich unbedingt an IP-Ad gewöhnen.
So.
Gut, Leute, ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Ähm,
guck,
was wir morgen streben sollen.
Ich werde das Ding nachher noch mal neu installieren, wenn ich,
und das P-Hall dann in irgendeinen Container verfrachten oder so.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
Pause.
See you.